here it's been a heck of a couple of
days has been a heck of a couple of
days yeah this actually turns out
recovering from this feels more like
recovering from taking like a a full
week of exams than it does from doing
any sort of physical activity so I'm
pretty sure I still couldn't add two
five digigit number in my head I'm
pretty sure maybe I could but the weird
thing is I have no desire to
try I basically don't want to have to
think about like anything that
involves discreet symbolic
manipulation so let's write some C
code well okay here here's the actual
plan um let's get rid of this get rid of
this get rid of this we don't need any
of that um so here's the plan for today
I am actually going to be using Claude
for
once just
initially uh just to get an initial Port
of the snake game to
see I'm going to see if I can get like
an endtoend demo of
that and um on top of that I'm going to
see how the python interface looks and
generally what I'm trying to figure out
here is if it's going to be possible to
have like a standalone
demo of some of the puffer Ms that can
also be run on web while being very
simple this is also just an excuse to do
something fun and different because like
thinking about my normal work at the
moment just hurts my head um for the
next day or two until I recover from
this fully so yeah we're just going to
have some fun and maybe do something
that ends up being very valuable for
puffer maybe not regardless we're going
to have a bit of a fun time doing this
so let me start
with where's
Claude
okay let me see how I want to set this
up put this
here put this like
this um what we're going to
do
oops Lo snake
H let's grab the initial
Port I think this is the initial code
right
yeah
so this is how we fix paste as it turns
out so this is our initial
rewrite 238
lines are you rewriting the snake M yeah
Noah but this is just an experiment like
you're not going to have to do any of
your stuff and see basically this is an
experiment to see if I can put some of
these things online as like web demos um
and I'm also just doing something
different because I'm fried from the
50k
so
yeah keep going on your
stuff there's no performance reason to
write it in C instead of
scon is this good let me
see oh yeah this is what we just copy
pasted
right and
then let me see if I like this
okay so it did it it made header files I
don't like that this is going to be it's
header only is what we're going to do
I'm not doing header and and
implementation we're not doing that
we'll do four declarations if we have
to here is scy on code that uses memory
okay so this is
good
into
IX set
fine and then here they have this okay
these are the allocators and the
ah all
right we can get rid of
these the other reason I'm doing this is
just like the way I do things I think I
would really enjoy writing stuff and
see um and I think the only reason I've
never really done that is because I had
the absolute worst systems lecture
imaginable in undergrad it was actually
like the worst two classes I've ever
taken and since then I've actually come
around I really like a lot of the
systems work I do I think it was just
ruined for me by just having just like
God awful uh University classes like
holy hell I don't even know know how
it's possible to screw up of course is
that
car we don't need this.h doesn't realize
that we're just making header
only also is there um is there a way to
do this directly in in
chat let me just let me tweet at them
real quick because actually they do
reply and it would be nice to have
cool oh quality of classes is a huge
factor for both of my enjoyment and how
much you can actually learn I thought
most of mine were terrible honestly like
a good course can be very useful I I'm
going to say 80% of the courses I've
ever taken have just wasted my
time stuff on my mates and I liked
because I knew a topic my own yeah I
would not do AI computer science proam I
would not do any of the stuff that I'm
currently doing if I thought it was
going to be if the day-to-day work was
what I what like I'd been presented from
undergrad like holy hell
there's like this huge amount of
emphasis which I understand is important
for like academic development right but
there's this huge amount of emphasis on
like solving tricky problems instead of
how understanding how to build things
right and I hate solving tricky problems
like think about it why like why would I
want to solve something that's hard for
the sake of solving that something
that's hard I want to solve something
that does you know a ton of awesome
stuff with the minimal amount of effort
possible
Right really bad really relatable
academic yeah I had a couple really good
courses I always tell people uh who are
trying to get into AI to go do cs231n
online because that was one of the few
courses I took that was like really good
and it's actually really funny I
remember like hearing the stupidest
comments when I was in undergrad at
Stanford people would say like oh 231 in
yeah it's an easy class like
the class the point of a class is not to
be hard it's to teach you something if
you it needs to be hard in order to
teach you something then so be it but
the point is to teach you something not
to like if you want to do something hard
go over like train for a race right
that's
hard it's like this weird sort of like
academic self-adulation I don't know
RB
renderer okay yeah here's the RB
renderer
um it made a separate main function
that's kind of
obnoxious so it did a few kind of weird
things here we'll
just
oops put this here for now
get rid of this other main
file because this isn't going to show us
anything anyways
right
here food corpse I think these are
defined up here
food
right empty food yep we don't need these
uhuh and here's the
renderer typed upst
struct
cool mediocre University of Technology
finished a top university he learned way
more math I know most technicality is in
networking
yeah honestly
like the the things that are really nice
about the the top universities right
it's
the being able to meet lots of smart
people is really good for your like your
own intellectual
development and uh the brand Associated
right it just it gives you a a starting
point to do other stuff
from the courses are not necessarily
better but oh yeah the other thing is
the access to research and like to being
able to to talk to to really good
researchers that's like the other really
big
thing hi
welcome okay this actually looks kind of
reasonable
um I am positive this is not going to
work first
try because llms are garbage right let
me see how I want to do this though I
think
can I just
like I actually do want to do this with
um upper
lib I want to do this with um clang at
some point or maybe the zig build system
so I get some extra
tools slop slop slop yeah it's slop but
will to be fair I'm using this to
translate code that I wrote I'm not
having it Implement stuff for
me this is an initial Port from scon
Toc we're going to see if this Lop
actually works if this slop causes me
three hours of compile errors then I'm
like blocking everybody who told me
Claude that's Claude is uh good I'll
maybe make an exception for you if I see
some cool Minecraft stuff
why switching to full C well um so my
brain is not exactly working today
because
of brain is not working today because
where's the stupid post because of this
it's going to take a few days so I just
wanted to try out something fun um and I
want to see if I can generate like
Standalone builds that I can run on the
web because this would let me do
everything through web assembly and such
so I don't know I feel like trying
something can I just do
this you need to be able to include rb.
right how do I
include I know you can just put the H in
the same directory is there a better way
of doing
it see
I think you are literally just supposed
to copy the files aren't
you I'm pretty sure that's what you're
supposed to do
wait that doesn't make sure sense
there's got to be no there is a build
system I'm dumb I don't want to do cake
yet you need that so you do need to
actually have a okay cool there is not
like a global install right okay there's
not like a package manager or anything
like that right it's
see my third year CS undergrad and have
to pick a specialization and would love
your
advice oh jeez that's hard um so the
really hard thing about picking a
specialization when you're in undergrad
is that if you haven't actually done
like the work that you will be doing in
that specialization which is completely
different from what you do in classes
you basically have no signal
right because like what you do in your
undergrad is going to have absolutely no
relationship
whatsoever um to what you're going to be
doing outside of
that I mean the best thing I can suggest
you is to just start doing a couple very
small quick projects like do some side
projects and stuff and see how you like
the actual work of doing stuff in these
areas right
that's pretty much the best advice I can
give
you like I'm in I'm in AI but 80% of my
playbook is
engineering my playbook is like 15% 15%
just like scientific method like basic
do good science 5% math and like 80%
just do good engineering
if I wanted to go like actually I pretty
much do pretty heavy systems for AI
these days that wasn't a terribly hard
switch to
make things that would be hard for me to
get into at the moment really
theoretical Theory heavy side ml I
probably wouldn't be able to do very
easily uh HCI I wouldn't be able to do
at all just I wouldn't enjoy it either
um security I'd be able to
do good fundamentals always
help your undergrad specialization like
the difference of a couple classes is
really not going to make a huge huge
difference it's more so what you've
managed to do
course
H and just do this and then
GCC it's really nice having tools run
instantly you know
I don't need this function for
now good idea try yeah you really need
the project experience and you needed
ASAP like if you've just been focused on
coursework like it I like to tell people
like if you just do your coursework in
undergrad you're qualified for nothing
you literally you are not qualified for
any job anywhere in computer science or
programming or anything at all like you
really incs there's this huge amount of
stuff that you have to do outside of
your coursework to be able to
function like relatively speaking CS is
a very very easy major like it's nowhere
near the difficulty of doing something
way heavier math or engineering heavy
but you have to do like substantial
independent
okay I don't know how to use GCC it's
been that
long this is why we do this is why we do
the silly side projects on a day where I
have the best excuse in the world for
not being able to
function
while better while with
p for
what do you
think okay questions what do we think
about AI scientists I haven't read it
yet I'm not capable of reading it for a
few days until my brain
recovers uh initially it's like the
people on that paper are really good so
I don't think it's just like full false
but I don't believe like I don't believe
it's possible that they're automating
science like how like language models
are basically only useful in very very
very narrow capacities for me at the
moment they can't do anything
substantial so I don't see how they
would be automating science I have to
read it though I know a lot of the
people associated with that and they're
very good but I don't know how are we
feeling after the 50k I feel like I have
not run a 50k I feel like I've taken a
week of exams like I can't add two
five-digit numbers in my head right now
it's like that bad um I I'm able to get
up and walk I can like go walk like half
a mile to go get my breakfast walk half
a mile back probably couldn't do any
heavy lifting or any actual running now
but yeah I can walk around and stuff
just fine but like I'm sleeping 12 14
hours a day and uh yeah it's it's pretty
rough okay why can't I run this
if you skim through generated papers
they're only tested on very simple
benchmarks and ideas are pretty simple
well simple ideas is not necessarily bad
but I also I have a weird model of
Science in my head at the moment because
like at least in
RL like I think ideas are really cheap
at the moment like ideas are really
really cheap execution is everything and
that's something language models can't
do look automated incremental ideas
would be fine like if the thing could
just consistently build on itself then
we'd be set but
like it's kind of funny to me that the
first thing that AI people try to do is
they try to do the thing that they know
it's like well I know how to do science
let me all try to automate science yeah
but automate like that's really hard
like I mean AI is not easy right like if
you were to say like oh yeah we have a
paper automating rocket science people
would look at you like you're nuts right
well AI is not easy right it's it's up
there for
sure there just so many like there's a
lot less math in most of it but there
are like so many things that need to be
things of course I say that as I'm like
forgetting how to use
GCC but it's okay I haven't done C in
like close to 10 years and my brain is a
no worker
today wait oh can you not
call can you not put a main in a header
file is that a thing
why but wait you should be able to it's
just not a good idea right
mark what do I need I just need Raab
don't I no I don't even need any of that
I just need um
previous definition of main with type
int
what
um is it like caching or
to do I have to put this
in in here as well
no there no the only main function is in
here this is like probably 50% me being
like brain not functioning and 50% me
not having dealt with like Rossy in
literally 10
years so far I'm actually very happy
because like stuff running instantly
this feels like okay this is how
software should work right stuff should
just compile and run
instantly not having shitty like
overbuilt tool chains Python and stuff
is really nice
but what the hell is
this in function init render oh wait
wait in init
renderer okay so wait this error is
in it's in the other file
right in function to knit render okay
perfect because this
is yeah yeah yeah so this is in here it
can't find RB stuff
right so the question is why can't it
find RB stuff
um init window this should be defined in
R.H
right
oh it's showing me
right oh it's showing me the if these link errors this just
the if these link errors this just
showing like after it's added all this
code here this include basically just
paste everything right so this is like
pasting RB and pasting everything else
and then it's saying
that there's no reference to an IT
window there
I was told a while ago that clang has a
lot of
nicer
Flags oh wait when compiling you must
explicitly link against
RB if it's not in a standard
location it is in a standard location
on I think this is a bogus command but
it shouldn't
hurt okay so let's get rid of this one
since
help am I dumb for thinking that I
should get an error if it can't include
or
something is this not in the RB core but
I get errors for AIT window which is
definitely in the core
undefined reference to a net
window maybe the rib docs have something
on this maybe there's like a specific
way you have to compile
compile dug deeper into AI scientists
found a lot of odd assumptions and
points if you read the paper you find
out that nothing is really that novel of
a finding they found that Claude is good
at coding if given templates is good as
it is good at filing them in and models
love to take positive spins on even
negative
findings all the things we they pretty
pretty much already knew so yeah that's
basically I just said like the way to
convince me I said this yesterday the
way to convince me of something like
this is to like show me some cool stuff
that it found right
settings how do
oh wait you
need I'm so
confused should I be using the binaries
how does this freaking work
that would make sense I should be able
to just use the
binaries coolest finding was also
nothing to do with papers but how it
tried to hack the initial rules was
given a time span it was allowed to
research under instead of trying to
speed it up it just tried it tried to
increase the time allotted
instead that's funny
dashd that doesn't seem like it's a good
idea
if you have the library in a dash
idea if you have the library in a dash in a lib directory
[Music]
lab is it source do you link to
here or do you link to
build no this build is my own my own
stuff how do we do
this I see somebody already asked
this wait
uh oh wasn't here
wait wasn't here for oh I see somebody
already asked this but I'm curious are
you creating this lib and see having a
rapper for usage in Python for the
public was originally written in so no
I'm doing so first of all the thing I'm
doing is kind of just exploratory for
fun for like today tomorrow whatever I
feel like while I'm recovering and if it
ends up being useful I'll keep doing it
there are a few motivations for this one
was I just wanted to screw around
writing some C and like doing some lower
level stuff the second motivation
is build rayb find that one sec will um
the other motivation here is just like
if I it was written in syon already so
it's already fast but if I can do it in
c as a standalone then I can potentially
run it on web and put together some
really cool demos and uh puffer lib
really could use some exposure at the
moment we're going to launch some stuff
soon and it will be like an order of
magnitude more people will see it and
play with it and you know interact with
it if I can get it online and I
categorically refuse to just like do
this all in JavaScript I like it's
either I'm going to figure out how to do
it as a standalone see or I'm just not
going to do it like screw
JavaScript um one build rib find the
static Library stop find the static
binaries so they ship binaries
already I think do I just have to
download the
binaries that would make sense right I
shouldn't need the source I should just
be able to download the
binaries bro I used to know how to do
all this as well
this I used to know how to do all
this it sucks because
like I honestly think um lower level
programming is something I would enjoy a
ton if it weren't just so utterly
poisoned for me when I like I learned it
in undergrad with just like the terrible
terrible lectures and
such um this
one can I get a link to
this so better late than
never Pearl
DL what is this
named go do
it a
[Music]
lib was it five
the
VF
uh what where is
it oh r five
and now we have rib 5 MD
Linux and now I need to figure out how
we the flags for this I
think oh so it's just this path right
here so it's RB 5 Linux
amd64 rayb 5 I literally can't remember
things that's crazy RB 5.0
it's like I could not remember a
four-digit number right now I'm pretty
sure uncore Linux
amd64 Linux
link against A- a or s o does this
already have the path because it should
be in there right
lrb do you need this D L rib flag is
this like exported by this or
something [ __ ]
[ __ ] um
now this is the web thing we don't need
this so there are a bunch of flags here
that probably are
good this came from chat jity I don't
know if this flag is
real using ra binaries
all right let's see if it does
it uh me a rib build command to link
against statically against the rayb
binaries on
Linux and
include header files
confused five what's in
here oh okay it's just include in lib so
that's easy
then so this is just going to be ra
5.0 Linux
AMD 64
slash slash include right and
then Ray
[Music]
lib like this
right you need to link against the
binary
this check the incl yeah it is that's
it's there I just did
it's includ in lib
right which has
theh and it's got the lib which has the
B which has the uh the A and the
SOS maybe slash on the paths at the
end that actually something you need to
do I also don't know if this L rid flag
exists
um is that a thing or did chat GPT make
that up
error dude why does that not give you an
error it just silently
fails is there like a flag you have to
turn on to give it if to give you errors
slash well built now and it didn't build
it
before cannot open lib
r.o.
isn't it in
here lib r.o. 500 it's there
isn't in a
directory D what the
[ __ ] I should not have to do this I
really shouldn't have to do
this okay well that didn't even help
anyways good job chap Dippity oh cuz I
oh it does something this is not
snake it is
runs I'm very surprised it even runs to
be honest with
you so that's good job Claude I guess
flag DL my library name tells it to look
for a file
named
lib okay or similar name prefix with lib
if
Dynamic if it's
found in user lib
then linking is
like should rib be set up to
automatically build there so like if I
build raay is it going to go to user
local lib or do I have to move it there
manually include several standard system
directories plus any you
specify with Dash Okay I need to
understand how build systems work at
some point here
um
cool you have to move it
there all right so we'll figure out I'll
figure out some standard way of of doing
this let me see if I can
understand this game and what is
happening here it's kind of cool that
this builds at
all is there
um is there any like build chain I
should be using to like give myself some
more reasonable debugging or something I
could go figure out
GDB I've heard clang has some stuff but
like I want to figure debug some stuff
did Claude translate the game well kind
of something renders but nothing
happens um so A for
effort um we'll see what exactly is
wrong with it
I'm actually very impressed that it even
like builds anything so that's kind of
cool first refactor the
game it is already mod it is already
modular what do you
interesting it's kind of funny because
this is like the only thing I would
consider using stuff for like is
translating initial drafts and I
probably wouldn't even do that if I like
I don't know this feels useful but
because I'm only but only because I'm
basically brain dead at the
moment if you gave me the code I bet I
could get it to do
it in like two shots
do you want the C code or do you want
the source code for
snake
um I'll give you hold on I'll give you
code I actually I got it to be pretty
good to start with here I'll show you do
you want I can commit this if you want
if you want to see um the snake code is
right
here the source you didn't specify you
mean the the
scon or the like partially like the C
that I have at the moment that kind of
works okay syon
cool this is so it's right here well me
send this to
you it's not python it's syon
yeah it's already very very close to the
C as
well which is why I thought this would
be good
I actually gave it some specific
instructions as well um I got it to
do
here yeah I I honestly I think I'm going
to have a fun time with just coding
stuff in C um we'll see about
that obviously like the day the goal is
to just like do some very limited
experimentation over the next couple of
days it's kind of difficult for me to
convey just how completely wiped out I
am by that 50k it's
like I don't know if you get the thing
where like you just your brain will just
like skip frames or like just skip like
things that I as I'm reading them or
something but it's pretty
rough like I don't really remember the
last time I was this just like mentally
I don't know if I like switch statements
like
this are you translating the python into
and the
scon so the python is just a binding um
I'll show you what I did so you
have I did get it to do a little bit of
the scon I'm not testing that at the
moment this is literally just a binding
so that like I'm using scon here to pass
memory views into uh into C so that I
don't have to do deal with like P bind
or C types or stuff so I'm still using
scon for that I haven't tested this yet
I don't really care about that uh yet
but um the python section that does get
translated there
is snake snake. py so if you look at
this RB client this is in Python but
it's using the C style API so it's
basically almost identical to the ecode
already um so I had it translate this
into
c as
M what branch is this I linked it to you
didn't I
Dev I can commit this C if you want as
well I don't know if it's
useful
2020 snake length
Branch kind of weird how this did that
let me see if I
can
so the keys definitely don't do
anything
it does
reset I don't know why the food is like
um I don't know about these switch
statements it like switch statements a
lot think the if the lfs might just be
cleaner I do like the do whils that it
uses those are actually kind of
nice let me see if I can figure out
where it would be going wrong
here action is equal to m. actions of I
yeah
it's got this weird format because it's
ported directly from scon but that
shouldn't
matter this is because you can't declare
variables in Loops in
syon because it follows python
scoping
here this break gets you out of the
switch
right snake length
likely can I like check this for weird
things where it's like going out of
bounds somehow is there like a clang or
something flag I can
use cuz like math like this worries me
let's say this
is I
times Max snake length times two
this is it doing it's doing like it
turned my one uh my arrays into like 1D
arrays and it's doing the math out for
that I don't exactly know
why he has multi-dimensional arrays
doesn't it yeah it does I don't know why
it's doing this
snake I can add like a print f for
actions at least
right I oh you need a parenthesis I
equals z print f
do this
right include standard
IO you're smart
damn I assume that's meant to be ironic
given that I'm acting completely brain
dead at the
moment in which case like you run a 50k
and then attempt to
function okay it is actually registering
key
presses this is exactly what it's
supposed to be
I'm trying to think even how it would go
going to stream this yeah go ahead I'll
go check your uh here I don't think I
have the sound forwarding but I'll pull
it up as well let me know when it's
up
jeez maybe coffee helps
it's also weird to me that the m is
resetting it
all is it possible that the renderer is
just
m.
grid draws a rectangle this looks fine
to
me this looks fine to
me unless is it not updating the grid
somehow like maybe it's not doing the
updates on the grid maybe it defined
like something else
I don't see grid
anywhere oh here it
is m. grid is
empty oh wait where does it do the other
grid
stuff snake colors of eye
Okay so
okay if you see this here it's
definitely
like the rendering is definitely wrong
right
because you can see that snake is moving
but it's not moving on the render
so okay so it is actually getting to
here
but then if it's getting to here there's
nowhere that should be able to break out
right it should
right so this whole the whole logic Loop
is in fact
running but
[Music]
somehow somehow the render isn't getting
updated
R yeah that doesn't make
sense let me see will stream whatever we
pull up will stream real
this I he was close to 3K and I sort of
just bumped him up let me grab WI
stre puffer lib is Claude 3.5 really
[Music]
Lop I mean how hard did we have to Nerf
me in order to make that even a
consideration
right is the question
well uh oh my sound is not working
because my headset is not plugged
in hold on
else
where I see if while he's doing this I
can also debug
I don't know if you're also listening to
this will but um X11
is I imagine it's for the
rendering this is very amusing because
Will loves like Will loves
all these LM tools for Dev and I
generally hate
them cuz they never
work and he's here like can we make this
slop
work
yeah you probably can if you make if you
spend enough time on it but the question
is like if you just know what you're
doing you can also probably just make it
work faster and better
right I'm still on the
on the board of just like get good LM
doesn't help you get
good I'm trying to see what's wrong with
this
render y * width plus X this should at
the very least I would think be updating
slop slop
slop I don't know oh wait yeah you do
have it on with with uh
slop oh wait I can't open his let me
open this thing on the on like my I have
the wrong tab open
go dude what the heck how do I why why
is there no chat pop
works I'm trying I still can't figure
out why the heck the render is
wrong it's it really looks is it just
not updating the frame at all
let me
see if render is not
null render
n this looks good to
all right let me just see if I can wake
up and find this um because this is
going to get boring very quickly
otherwise
so next R next
C they should be updating the grid
right they should be updating the
M let's see what did this fill
in next
row wait next
R okay this is the
anything
okay so it shows that it's filling it in
with zero okay so that's the issue is
that it's updating but it's like it's
not for some reason it's filling this
something okay so color is constantly
zero you can
see it's an eight colors
okay so this is clearly
something something wrong here it's I
think that it's I think what's happening
is just like we're putting the wrong
data onto the
grid uh let me
see
hell oh okay
cool
yeah all
right so
um it yeah so maybe I I'm listening to
you I have your stream open um so I it
could be the large the like the gigantic
version it could just be one pixel per
snake cell which is like the fullsize
one and it could just not be doing the
colors um yeah
it's it yeah but that's like that's
possibly
correct
uh oh jeez uh it [ __ ] when you're you
can't be streaming my audio or I'm
listening to you listening to myself um
so what happens is like you see up here
how I have it here um where is it width
and height there should be a cell size
as
well do you see the cell size here like
it should be defining a cell size that
tells you like what the size of the
board is so that should not be one pixel
and then uh there should be in your C or
what ever there should be a parameter
that tells you uh the width and the
height and the number of snakes like
this yeah this is what you
want so I think that mine is like
similarly I think mine is actually
fairly close but I think it got the
colors wrong so check if it got the
colors wrong as well cuz I think that's
what's most uh most likely
I I think now you muted your whole
stream will instead of just like my
instead of just
myself okay there you
colors oh does it just not set these I
think it just didn't set these right
yeah it didn't it didn't handle colors
at all
okay
colors yeah it just didn't handle the
colors at
all I bet this isn't I bet this will do
the exact same thing and screw up the
colors
yeah what the heck this is very
weird I'm kind of confused that it just
didn't handle the colors at all I mean
that's AI slop
it okay it didn't the the uh it didn't
allocate the didn't do the colors
whatsoever that's what
happened so let's check this
of whatever we'll do it inside of
allocate sne snake as defaults for
sir paid
slop paid
slop I'm still not sure what what it did
with the colors I think I need to go
look at my original code to see what the
hell how I implemented this
originally yeah let me see how I did
colors okay so there was actually this
colors thing
here
trying to figure out where I did the
colors
isn't this the Twitter
API yeah the Twitter
yeah I'm trying to figure out where did
I heck what did I do with these colors
anyways did I just have them at the top
somewhere four plus a range
oh I just
did I did zero
through I no I'm confused what the heck
I did does it
work kind of
territory I'm just trying to remember
what the heck I
did this is actually slop yeah
just
unfollow yeah this is
fun
it's such
slop dude it's such slop it's [ __ ]
it's literally synchronized why is it
it's literally
synchronized
yeah and now you got to go spend an hour
like figuring out what the heck it
yeah you also realize like the design of
this environment this is so
that yes they are they are allowed to
eat the
corpse That's funny
though where the heck is this snake
colors
I mean obviously if I'm like coding in
something I have no familiarity with I'm
going to be screwed
yeah I can give my take on this if I
want but like the TDR is like no you
have to get good though
what dude I got all the excuses in the
world today all right I'm
fried I am
fried all right I'm trying to do stuff
and see which I haven't looked at in 10
years on a day I'm totally
fried like it's going to take my brain
like another two or three days to even
remotely recover um yeah
the troll will will is like way more
optimistic and stuff than I am he's like
really like glass half full I'm like the
glass is freaking empty but you can fill
the glass if you get
good it's funny he gets a kick out of it
though uh
it's
funny all right let me see if I can do
something interesting here I'd like to
fix this I we'll look at Will's version
as well
the bit map yep that's what I would do
as well it's still not good
yeah it's doing weird stuff that you
can't
do yeah you
can't you
can't I've kind of like I've gone
through this already you can't you can
make it faster you can't make this very
fast
you can do some tics I guess but like
it's not you don't really need it either
like we just use the neural nuts it's
fine
yeah yeah yeah I this is the thing this
is why you don't do the AI slop right
you
like no slop
I kind of don't want to iterate on the C
file with an LM I want to write the
C okay he's got a he's asking like he
wants to know what I would do next with
this h
yeah I'll tell him
so open
here ah
[ __ ] okay I'll mute you so I'm going to
mute I'm I have you muted now [ __ ] this
is so dumb we got to figure out how to
co-stream at some point will let's not
do this today CU I'm actually freaking
brain dead um here I I have you muted so
this is this is what we're going to do
for for now um so the goal of this whole
thing was if you can Port this to c then
you can run this Standalone um and
you'll hopefully be able to do
everything on web I did a little bit of
testing and what we were able to do is
we were able to very easily build rib
examples for web so there are two things
that need to be done first is that this
needs to be bound to the python side so
that we can train stuff um your options
for that as far as I can tell are like
Pi bind or C types or cffi or just use
cython for The Binding you need to have
memory uh you need to have what is it
called memory views uh in order to get
the numpy arrays easily into the crra
format so that needs to be done so that
you can actually train it and then the
other thing that needs to be done is we
need to be able to uh export the trained
P torch models with torch jit script uh
torch. j. script or whatever and then
load them probably I think that's a C++
API so we'll have to have like a little
C++ bind maybe the main file is C++ and
then the whole like implementation is c
um so that we can run the trained policy
Standalone with torch jit script and
then I can put this whole thing online
on like puff GitHub bio or whatever and
then that's like a cool end to end demo
where you have uh a train neural network
controlling like 4,000 snakes in real
time in your browser and you get to play
one of them but when you take your hands
off the keyboard like it will start
controlling the snake for you I have all
of that working and it works really
really fast locally but I can't put it
on the web because it's like scyon
instead of c and like you know python
for the networks and all of that I'm
going to unmute the stream
now oh jeez if I okay I got to wait
until my stream catches up so it's I'm
not listening to myself
this is not that
simple this is not that
yeah hey Joseph why for C I'll tell you
in a second let me hold
does let me oh yeah go check out will
stuff as well will does some
stuff de what the [ __ ] did you just
paste the entire did you just paste the
entire
Source uh dude it just deleted
that what the
heck one sec I'll explain this C stuff
in a second we're having a bit of fun
one
sec let me send him
command yeah I just sent him the M
script
in so what we're doing
here man I wish I could actually like
collab and like work on this stuff today
but it's just everything's moving so
slow
so okay let me explain what's going on
here so first of all I'm just doing
whatever I can for the next couple days
cuz I am beyond fried from a 50k um ran
on Monday and now I'm just like complete
brain dead um but the idea was like Hey
what if we just write one of these M's
in C and run rib web assembly and like
use torch jit script on the model so we
have the entire thing demoed end end on
the web that'd be really cool um so I
started on this stuff and will thinks
that Claude can just do all of it which
like and maybe some of it we'll see is
also making some slop in the
process Will's cool though go follow
yeah so this actually should work but I
don't think it's going to he's going to
be able to get it quite on the well
actually no it would actually run on the
web immediately this will run on the web
immediately it's the getting torch stuff
integrated that's harder
on a side note have you compared crafter
on puffer Li with
craftex yeah there's no way that puffer
can make crafter fast that like that's
there's literally no way to make crafter
fast in this current implementation it's
the worst [ __ ] code I've ever seen if
I were to implement crafter myself I
could get it to be as fast as craftex on
CPU but there's no way that puffer can
just like make crafter fast I'd have to
implement their end
yeah I linked I gave him the link
command that works oh on CPU yeah I can
totally make craft crafter run a million
SPS on CPU
easily very easily like basically
Muhammad like
at this point it's like if I know that
like making a thing will get me a th
followers on X I'll just do it and I can
do it in a week I'll just do it like
we're but like we're making lots of Ms
now it's just going to be a matter of
like which Ms do people want and which
are going to get eyes on puffer etc
etc I would sit through all Dev if you
do it it wouldn't be that hard it really
wouldn't be that hard
him hello I saw your thesis vid and
whoops one
second one second there so I saw your
thesis vid con inspired me using MDD to
create deep RL for MOBA games is my CS
bachelor's degree Final War any
advice
wait have you seen you've seen the MOBA
stuff that I've been posting lately
right this is not like completely
independent thanks for uh thanks for the
words by the way on the the thesis um we
literally have like a mooba that's well
underway that you're more than welcome
to like come try to help contribute to
um it's going very very well
what do you mean what is MDD markof
decision
something what's
MDD we're doing like a weird semi broken
co- stream thing at the
moment model
driven I've never heard that term before
what is that
moment something like uml the code oh
jeez I generally recommend staying away
from
like yeah I generally recommend staying
away from all framework things like that
um DRL for m is good MDD not so sure
about
crafter is faster than that it can get
puffer Li so much attention yeah is
Claude 3.5 really slop yes yes it is I
agree but this is funny cuz like you can
open will stream as well Wills are
really good Dev we just do things really
differently like I do not lean heavily
on AI tooling like at all this is kind
of just like a for fun thing uh Will
loves all the AI integration it's like
cursor everything right you know
everything is like Auto AI refactor is
very
funny
yeah he's going to get this thing
working way before me on the web today
which is fine like I got I'm I'm out of
it there's no way
I didn't see your MOBA stuff oh man
you're going to be really interested in
that that's crazy that you just
randomly that's going to be I got
Christmas is coming early for
you Christmas
is yes hold on let me
hold on okay let me show you this thing
that I made you're going to be really
really happy about this like Merry
Christmas to
FPS where the heck is
it oh yeah there it is so here this is
an ultra high performance mob for
reinforcement learning written in python
it runs in pure C it's only like 1300
lines single file no dependencies has
five different hero classes has the
exact same map as DOTA exact same Tower
placement creep placement Etc has creep
waves um you can see like this it runs
has multiple different render modes this
is one of the things I've been working
on uh it trains at like 500,000 SPS it's
like thousand times faster than what you
would expect yeah there you
go so that's what I've been working on
as one of my projects
the slop could have worked that was an
actual quote
[Laughter]
holy sounds great let me check that out
yeah and it's all free it's all open
source just like swing by
stream it's I'm I'm live pretty much
five days a week just deving stuff
there's been like this week is a little
bit weird because I ran a 50k on Monday
so I'm basically just out I'm just like
out at this
point um yeah
so yeah usually this is like a much less
dumb stream but uh today it's like I'm
just doing whatever I
can and we're having a good time messing
around with Will
here he basically came on and like hey I
bet you know Claude can just do all the
stuff that you're doing today and it's
like well it probably can cuz I'm not
exactly able to do anything so it kind
of works causing a bunch of bugs and
errors that aren't going to be a fun
time to fix as you can
see
yes yeah you do have to build ra for web
followers
cool all right he'll be all he'll get
bored of this in a few minutes I'm sure
um and we're going to have to fix this
ourself
but
yeah can I at least run something while
I'm waiting for
this snake colors I still don't
understand what the hell this was
supposed to do
and it's C
snake m. snake colors equals snake
colors I don't know why it doesn't give
me my auto correct in in here yeah let's
just do like this
is this is this this
intax I'm so annoyed because I have
like snake
colors oh yeah it is this is the
is this thing actually buildt wait I
think he says he got it to build let me
see he might need H might need to do uh
he might need to make a server
well yeah BR uh was it
Franco you can let me know if uh if you
have any questions on the M but that's
all online
online
yeah the build bullshit's annoying
what is where is the snake M again it's
in poer lib it's in uh it's in the dev
Branch it's like environment's ocean
snake
slop I'm getting into this RL stuff so
it's a lot to assimilate
I see you have all your Dev episodes so
I might check them out yeah so I'm on
Twitch YouTube X um this is a little bit
of an unconventional time because like I
said I'm fried this week but basically
by next week you're going to see there's
going to be consistent Dev on like
making all this RL stuff simple and easy
check out puffer it's the main project I
work on it full-time again this week is
a little weird um but yeah normally
we're just doing stuff
is no that would not be fun will all
deep learning in C++ would not be very
dude he does not know the infrastructure
he's
missing this is not going to work this
is where it's this is going to be
work I still know what happened with
this
thing that's why I hate the AI slop
because I don't know how to fix this
now I didn't write it right it it I
wrote it but then it ported it and it
did weird stuff
snake yeah I link the damn Source
already
yeah link the source so I
cannot have you also trained a model
yeah it trains in like a minute or two
trains super
fast so the thing that's the context
that's missing here is this environment
is not AI slop this is like very
carefully designed environment that I I
wrote this is just being translated from
scon which is basically already C into C
native did he DM me
this no he didn't DM me this
we'll show some stuff on the snake m in
a bit
here this is where you get into the AI
slop it's just causing
issues that's what you don't get from AI
slob
yeah it like the thing is even if the AI
slop works like you're not learning
anything by using it so like you're just
like your skills are just staying
constant over time and like you're just
relying on the AI so what's your value
ad right like you're basically you're
you're adding nothing like oh I can type
in a prompt that makes it work that's
why I don't like I don't want to rely on
it that much anyways like I'll use it
for
autocomplete
yeah dude what are you freaking doing
man
autocomplete makes sense yeah it's good
autocomplete I mean this translation
stuff as you can see it's still kind of
slop like I wouldn't even use it for
translation if I had written C in the
last 10 years like at all and if I
weren't just totally fried today but we
were just trying we're just screwing
around doing some
stuff and as soon as Will's done here
we'll like we'll try to like lock in a
little bit and see if I can actually
make this thing work properly cuz I'm
going to have to fix up all the stuff in
this
h
well he has not linked the code still so
I guess we'll just still like screw
around with our version
um I still don't know what the H the
thing is like it screwed up when it it
screwed up on the port and I don't know
what the hell it did to fix it when I
would like the amount of brain capacity
I have left today is the problem
yeah how much SPS would you Target on 25
Ms 25 million pram
[Music]
Transformer well 25 mil Transformers is
too big that net is just too big for RL
yeah 25 mil is huge man like all of DOTA
was 168 mil right all of DOTA is like
168 mil and it's probably could have
been smaller than that like um like the
snake net we use is like 150k and it
just
works yeah I just want his freaking his
C file because I don't want to have like
at least that slot version runs and I
can mess with it from there
we're probably going to have to do a
little bit more slop stuff today just
because my brain doesn't work but I mean
at least I'll try to get it in a way
that like I don't let it do stuff that's
going to screw with the way that it's
built so I'll actually be able to make
some progress today
obnoxious what the hell this freaking
Auto thing let's say it's 10
mil xland 2 on 3D goes up too yeah but
the thing is like you got to realize
deep mine doesn't Implement their [ __ ]
efficiently like their M's are horribly
horribly slow so it makes sense for them
to have bigger Nets
yeah I will totally set up build configs
on
stream
bruh hopefully I can actually get into
this damn Discord
okay let me go get the stupid auto like
the
confirmations dude what the hell why is
it like it just made me a new Discord
account the
snake oh okay it's he's on slyther okay
cool
right let me I'll there's a little bit
of nuance Muhammad let me give me a
second and I'll answer
you where the heck is this
thing wait where is the code
in general what am I blind where's the
freaking code oh
here
cool you download
download this file cool now I have this
thing I have now I have this
so basically this question is like how
do we make RL work when like things are
not fast what you don't you have to fix
RL because the whole Field's freaking
broken and then we'll be able to make it
work there
now the thing he's suggesting Now does
not
work he's asking if you have unlimited
data but it's like a very short snippet
all collected in
parallel yeah this does not the thing is
describing now this does not make sense
well I don't think the thing is
suggesting makes sense
100 messages half of which are
mine I think the thing he's thinking
about here doesn't make sense
yeah I don't think that's a
fundamentally attractable problem
prioriti level replay yeah but the thing
is there's nothing to prioritize because
the policy is random at the start of
training that's the
okay let me answer some
questions and get back to this
code we're going to actually do a few
hours of real work here and do some cool
stuff let me see
um
so the thing is there's a lot of
subtlety in why I think this and it's
based off of a lot of stuff it's going
to be difficult to summarize but
essentially like virtually nobody in
reinforcement learning has bothered to
actually make their simulators like even
slightly
optimized at the same time we have lots
of proof that reinforcement learning
scales exceptionally well with data and
not well with parameters so like versus
language models where you train giant
Nets on a very small amount of data RL
wants you to train small Nets on a ton
of data fundamentally we have evidence
for this so it makes sense in my mind
the thing the way that we push RL
forward is we use little tiny networks
on tons of data with ridiculously fast
Sims we run exhaustive and comprehensive
experiments
and then we transfer those insights to
problems where we don't have you know as
fast of simulators or even better we
also just transfer the simulation
techniques right to make those problems
faster as well and we win on both fronts
um it absolutely doesn't make sense
right now to be using like 10 plus
million parameter networks though in uh
most of reinforcement learning I think
that we're actually at a regime where
like hundreds of thousands to maybe low
Millions at most is what we want to look
at we absolutely don't even want to look
at Transformers because of the uh just
the memory requirements of them though
there are a couple projects that have
kind of done okay with that and yeah
that that's kind of where I'm at
currently with stuff
um there has been a little bit of
attempt to make stuff fast lately but
it's kind of barking uh barking up the
wrong tree if you will like all the
stuff like craftex is the exception that
proves the rule with that like if you go
open the craftex code it's insanely
complicated it's like really that's an
impressive project I have no idea I I
hosted the author at a meeting and I
have honestly have no idea how he wrote
that it's like very very hard to write a
Sim like that in contrast though like I
could write that Sim just as fast way
way easier for CPU now the problem with
that is you need good vectorization to
actually take advantage of that but
that's what I've been building with
so now we actually have the full end to
end system to be able to do this type of
stuff now because craftex itself exists
already there's less incentive for me to
rewrite that particular environment for
fast CPU unless people really wanted it
um you know but it is out there you know
that is a possibility
so yeah that's that's kind of like the
long and the short of
have you tried something in
3D it depends what you mean right there
are a lot of games
that uh are only rendered in 3D and
technically have local 2D State like I
could write a 3D renderer for the MOBA
that I have right and then it would be a
3D game even though the state is 2D like
this is true for like DOTA League of
Legends right like all like the
rendering that you see like the 3D
character it's actually a 2d game same
as for like RuneScape MMOs a lot of
stuff like that they're all really just
2D uh if you mean like an
FPS or something like that where it's
fundamentally that way I haven't uh I do
know of something very similar that can
be made relatively fast um like hide-and
seek type stuff uh or Capture the Flag I
haven't done that yet but I am very
confident that I can also get that to be
several hundred thousand if not a
million uh steps per second single
threaded so we pretty much have the
formula down now for Sims we're pretty
much done on that
like it's just a matter of now doing the
work like we actually are on the track
where I think we've solved most of the
fundamentals
here if you're going by my thesis video
things have advanced like generationally
since my thesis for
oh come on man this code is such
slop what the
hell how's there no Malik in
here I put all these function prototypes
in
here if we are trying meta RL and want
to learn thousands of tasks we still
don't need more parameters
well there's a great way to check right
so what you do and we have this already
in puffer lib um you set like your say
like layer widths and like numb layers
in like your blocks or whatever you set
that as a hyperparameter and then you
just give it as a hyperparameter to your
tuning algorithm right and your tuning
algorithm uh is just going to record how
well your network does and how long in
seconds real training seconds it takes
so it will automatically make your
network larger if it needs to be larger
or it will make it smaller if it needs
to be smaller and it'll do everything
wall clock optimal that is the way to
go so you know we don't even have to
like think too hard about these
questions anymore when you have like M
Speed you can just automate everything
else
dude I wish I'd read this code while
will was actually doing this cuz holy
hell this is like some of the worst Lop
I've ever
seen how does this thing even run it
doesn't maloc any memory anywhere
there's no allocator
it has a global game
State okay this this code is absolutely
garbage wow will I [ __ ]
hell I love how that happens right how
that just like I this is actually the
worst slop I've ever seen holy
hell well I'm going to have to just fix
my M because this is useless
um best approach to something
fundamentally
3D take the 3dm and try to find a way to
create structures that represent the
game in 2D no not
necessarily not necessarily you just
have to not render the whole game right
you can potentially you just need to not
be doing too many raycast and things
like I can write stuff in 3D as well
it's not going to be a problem in fact
we're going to probably do that in a few
weeks for
fun no malaking is actually a sign of a
good code oh really is this sign of a
good code when the alternative was just
to define the struct already with
hardcoded constants on the size for it
and no way to change them
as this is written there's literally no
way to change the uh the size of the
game board and
stuff whatever is fast and doesn't take
time well this one just fundamentally
doesn't work as well as the the version
that I
wrote like this just doesn't let you do
the same
stuff and if you want to if you're
talking about Good code let me find the
block I was looking at before how's this
do for you
hey Will's
back will this is
[Laughter]
slop you see global game
State freaking
everything I actually had it implement
it the way that I had asked it before it
got the structure right there's just
there's some bugs in the implementation
oops
here so the way that I had it implement
this before right I had it pass in all
of the memory so there are no
allocations in the init but then there's
an optional method there's an allocate
method so if you want to just call this
from C without passing buffers in from
like numpy or something you can have it
do allocations and then I made it make a
d allocator here or free
here but it did something weird with the
logic so now I have a version that works
but has ridiculous stuff going on and I
have a version that doesn't work need to
hire somebody that can do great
documentation and blogging for you to
get this knowledge out there
um I do write my own blogs you know
there are a bunch of them on
X none of this stuff is documented
because it's all in Dev still right this
is all Dev Branch
stuff I work in like multi-month
increments for a lot of the bigger
updates know the tech
documentation so I mean this exists
right you have API signatures here
you've got some stuff here you've got
tutorials right you've got a demo file
here in collab you've got tutorials here
you've got a whole walk through of the
library what else would you want that is
not
here that's a serious question if you
tell me and I can write it I'll just add
it
carbs is also de brand Ranch man there's
no dock for it because I haven't pushed
it I haven't released it as an official
update
yet if anybody has not started the
puffer we're almost at 800 helps me out
a lot
here let me actually do the thing will
said and so and get Claude to fix some
stuff because I'm actually too brain
dead to do
anything
today SAR I don't know why no no no
that's not nagging me dude that's like I
want user feedback cuz I can't fix stuff
if I don't know that stuff doesn't make
sense right that's exactly what I want I
want like I want more people posting in
Discord like I don't know how to use
this thing or I get this weird error or
whatever so I can say oh okay you know
if five people ask for this then it's
definitely something where uh it's not
clear and I should spend some time to
add it
right I am using I am using Claude here
will one sec this came out of Claude
originally as
well this I have this open but I also
had Claude open
before see blink is purple
yeah 4 +
I was it 4 plus I this might have been
what it
was I might have just
fast something weird
here sent you a Discord cool
message oh I think did this go to like
the weird account that it just made me
for some dumb reason when I joined your
server hold on
this dude why is Discord like spinning
my CPU this much it used to be such a
good application and they've like just
bloated it to Hell over the years holy
hell
okay yeah there it's malaking stuff I
still had
it I gave it much more specific
instructions will so I think the layout
of how I have it in the other one is
better it's just that there it's like
there's some bug with it that I've got
to fix there like some bugs um here I'll
show you how I how I did this and why I
did it this way this came from the
design of the original environment as
well
so you can see that the init function
takes in a bunch of pointers to
allocated data this is so that if you
have the pbind or like the scon
API pretty cool to watch you Dev got to
run see you
um so yeah this is you can see there's
an Alec function
here which will do all the mem
allocations and stuff so that you can
optionally uh make this whole thing uh
from C and have it handle memory for you
or you can call the init with the python
binding
and pass in all these buffers so that
it's shared back and forth with
python I'm still trying to figure out
exactly what's
wrong in the Atari RL environment is
frame skip basically just repeating each
action end times yep that's all it
is frame skip is fine I don't know if
you're just this is like a general
question or the one based on my article
frame skip is fine sticky actions are
not
cursor It's A Hard Sell well well very
hard
sell you're also watching me do this on
a day where I'm basically nerfed into
the ground so it'll get
easier what's the motivation to use
frame skip uh it's the fact that the
data is very highly correlated from
frame to frame so you're basically just
throwing away like there's no point in
training on data that's that correlated
C wait what it just told me this is
exactly the same as before this code did
not
change send me the C
all
you ah wrong Discord hold
on don't use don't try to DM me on this
account by the way like we I should add
you on the main one like I it made me a
new account here for some weird reason
but here I put it in gen
removing the
tail tail and width
plus this ISS that this should
be next wait tail
r no these are exactly the same so it
just it said to like check the following
parts but this code didn't
change okay so this BAS basically it
gave me this one fix and then it didn't
do anything
else it's possible that is this the
frame rate wrong the frame rate could
just be wrong right
frame where is it
set maybe it's in the
H okay 60 FPS is way too much I think
it's supposed to be like 10 for
here this is like play playable
now kind of
playable there's some weird stuff going
on for sure though
right
okay if I hit the wall yeah okay it
kills you if you hit the wall so this
actually is somewhat working there was
some weird stuff before Oh if you just
keep going down like this it just keeps
respawning you that's why it looks weird
I see and it doesn't it doesn't spawn a
corpse if you're only one unit cell
large I think is what happens because it
only spawns half of the food
works that's actually kind of cool that
it got the port right first try
essentially first try I forgot to
allocate some variables
but
cool
so I guess now uh I'm going to go use
the restroom real quick and then we're
going to I'll see if I can actually like
make this thing useful and fix some
stuff up since I've kind of not done
much yet
today and uh we'll see where we can go
from there I'll be right
okay jeez I can actually walk for the
most part part
but it's not exactly
see
cool stream is over there perfect
so let's uh let's actually see what we
can do with this m now so we actually
have it
running Claude snake uh right there's no
script there's no like built-in script
today
so you're actually you're required to
provide all the actions which is not
going to work until we integrate this
with uh the neural net I don't think
we're quite ready to do that yet though
I think we should get this running on
the web
first which is the thing that will
did so let me
see the build thing that I sent him
right so these binaries actually are not
going to work anymore
because yeah hey I read your 50k article
hugely inspiring puffer lib too thank
you thank you very much yeah I feel I
thought that that was like I don't like
to share non RL stuff too much on
Twitter but like the exercise has just
been so so good for me personally and
way too many people in Tech like
prioritize just wa working working
working over health so I figured it
would be useful for
people the thing that made it click in
my head cuz I don't enjoy running at all
right I really don't enjoy running but
the thing that made it click in my head
is like you can train for a marathon in
a few months it's not actually that
crazy of a goal to do
like just why not do it right it's like
so good for your health it's like such a
huge difference in Fitness being able to
do that versus not and then I just built
a little bit from there right I kept
building a little bit from there that's
all of course the result of this is that
I'm completely fried today and uh barely
functioning which is why will is [ __ ]
mogging me with Claude
today but that doesn't that don't happen
normally
I'm GL let's figure out how we build
this I think we just need to
like get the entire rib stuff over here
don't we
here I was trying to do the WM thing
you're trying to do didn't spend enough
time on it just the whole DOTA Sim is
cool to look
at yeah we're going to make it work I
the thing is like it doesn't if I get
this to work here it doesn't mean it'll
work with the dosim I have to Port stuff
to see which we're basically we're going
to see how easy this is or not um I'm a
little bit torn here because like on one
hand it's really really good to have
some of these demos on the web it's just
going to do so so much for puffer it's
going to do so much for me like being
able to get this stuff out there but at
the same time I don't want people who
are like contributing to puffer thinking
that oh yeah in order to make these Sims
we you need to write everything in purec
like the reality is you can write in
scyon which is basically Python and if
you just follow the very very light
guard rails that I've set to make stuff
fast like you can trivially make million
FPS Sims
so it's it's a little bit torn in both
directions I think that the most likely
thing is that I'm going to want to have
like a few Sims Online to just sort of
showcase the work and then the rest will
be like you know just syon code
something like
that why do you have to Port stuff to C
can't you write it in syon the back end
and render it in the front end so think
about the stack required to do that
right like I have to have so now there's
a there's a front end and a back end in
the first place so you have to have a
server uh that's probably with
websockets communicating actions from
the client to the back end and the back
end has to have like nicely organized
packets that can be used by the renderer
to update the current visualization and
then also like you're now running the
neural networks as well the neural
networks have to run on the server side
so now I have to worry about like well
what if five people try to open this at
the same time like now all of a sudden
that doesn't even work anymore because I
need this to scale so basically like you
get to trade you get to decide whether
you want to have infrastructure held
behind this or if you want to have
everything be really really simple and
clean but just B andc right and I don't
know I honestly don't know if either of
these are going to be useful this was
just like a fun random idea I had that I
thought would be a cool thing to do for
the next few days while I
I really like the idea of being able to
run it in the browser yeah I
mean so basically the thing that has to
happen is in the next few months here um
the growth on puffer has been amazing
thus far but it has to be much much
larger even than it is now the goal is
that in the next few
months there should be several companies
you know using puffer lib for their
reinforcement learning and hopefully
wanting support contracts with puffer
and this is a very good way for me to
get puffer out there and getting more
people to see it because ultimately you
know I'm currently working on all this
stuff for free and I'm fine with like I
don't have to worry about rent and stuff
that's not going to be a problem but in
order for me to really scale puffer I
need to start getting uh Revenue that I
can use to like build out more clusters
and machines start putting like bounties
on different problems around puffer
eventually think about hiring people and
I don't want to take VC money for that
so that means that while I'm am going to
be spending the vast majority of my time
on like core engineering to make puffer
itself better it is absolutely worth me
doing this type of a thing once in a
while to see if like maybe I can get
just I can get puffer out there get many
people playing with it and really like
seeing how this Tech is so fast and
easy would you have to hire employees to
support multiple companies with
puffer not
initially I could handle like five
myself just fine and then after that
probably yes as soon as I get like that
level though as soon as I have you know
that amount of traction then yeah I will
start getting a few people
it's all speculative for now right I got
to make the thing scale first
but yeah I mean that's kind of where my
head is at
because this whole thing is only worth
doing like all the stuff I'm doing with
RL is only worth doing if it comes back
ultimately to benefit the research space
right so I'm keeping everything free and
open source um but that does make it I
don't think it makes it less valuable
inherently but it does mean you have to
be a little bit more creative about how
you go about doing things so you know
getting that sort of initial takeoff is
moderately
difficult but it'll be there because the
tech is there like the tech is really
really good I'm very very happy with
what's happened here
what happened here chel
file Source
found oh that's weird my update didn't
get applied
directory huh I guess I didn't save the
file that was weird I've seen the snake
m is vectorized in the environment
itself would the actual SPS then be numb
snakes times SPS yes so when you say
steps per second it's technically always
agent steps per second that is always
the correct way to count um
experience is you want to know the it's
specifically if agents can die as well
and they have like a respawn time or
they don't respawn you you should
measure the number of observations agent
observations obtained per second that is
the correct way of measuring
it and you should include reset time for
the environment as
well what the heck happened here I
literally I did all this and it just
like it like undid my changes that was
weird
um well we'll just redo it
HTTP server hold on there's a command
for this that I
forgot apologize for off topic is it
okay to share a link here
resource uh you can try I you might have
to like edit the link there YouTube does
some really weird Auto mod stuff that I
can't figure out how to turn off so if
it deletes the link it's not me deleting
it it's just the Auto mod in puffer when
I run serial VM type does it turn does
it in turn also use one core or is that
the numb workers so puffer when you run
cereal cereal is one core the
multi-processing is multi-core uh what
cereal will do is it has it has a
somewhat optimized way of running
multiple environments per core but it's
not as optimized as like the internal
vectorization for multi snake right so
the idea for the puffer cereal is like
let's say you're running Atari and you
want to run uh you have eight cores and
you want to run 40 copies of Atari for
instance well then what you do is you
run five copies of the environment per
core and that will be wrapped in a cial
and then multiprocessing goes on top of
that versus running 40 individual
processes that are just going to be way
slower that's one of the main
improvements over gymnasium though of
course there's a lot more to
whatever
error nothing matches
I think you have to go into build
right ho ho look at this we're playing
snake on the web yeah we're playing
snake on the web that's cool
right we're playing snake
online that's
sweet and we didn't even need to do any
of that weird stuff that uh will was
doing with M script and and like in the
source code
where's cell size as well oh here it
is cell size like this 40 40
right d this is really annoying not
having super Maven working in these C
files especially since I'm just not used
to typing like Loop syntax like
this uh let me let me figure out why
it's not enabled in C
not working in C it's weird because it
works in myh
I don't know if anybody knows why the
heck this isn't
working that's that's like so obnoxious
because I don't have anything else I
don't have an LSP so this is editing C
with like no LSP and nothing which is
something that it is the type of thing
that I would do but like not when I
haven't written C in 10 years
what is there like a config for this
somewhere
this is why I hate using these tools you
get dependent on them though like in
this case it's just really like I'd like
to have a little bit of syntax complete
if I don't have an LSP because I haven't
used C in 10
years yeah this is
not man is there no like config file for
this thing somewhere
when trying to use puffer Li with carbs
I get a dependency
error shpi version from carbs uses
numpy
um okay that is good to
know let me think about that
I'm gonna make you a little issue for
this on the support
Channel this is what you can do for
these by the way as
well thank you I will try the ignore
file type uh one second
okay I will get to this um for now
easiest thing to do
is I think if you just pip install if
you just install puffer and then install
carbs I think it'll just work let me
know if that doesn't work you are using
uh puffer locally right cuz the dev
branch is what is required for carbs
carbs is only in
MD yeah I'm on dev
um are you on python 311 or whatever I
have not tried this setup locally I do
know it works in puffer
tank but I will gladly help you if I can
figure out I don't know if you can just
upgrade numpy to
2.0.1 you can try just pinning numpy to
2.0.1 inside of um puffer lib setup for
now I don't know if that breaks stuff I
probably
I don't have any ignores in here this is
very
weird the thing is the neovim config I
just opened this is a readme MD file
this is not a config this is an
example right
good I mean maybe this is the default
maybe it like defaults to C++ or
something
weird uh I don't actually have Lua set
up in this
though that's really obnoxious
we can just deal with it for now it's
okay I'll figure it out later I'm not
going to spend forever today on
this um you know just man up and
freaking write your write your C code
right it's not that
hard so what we'll do here is M actions
of
I
Rand percent 4
I think this
snakes EMCC command not found right
there was a thing that we had to do for
that now there's there's a thing we had
to do for this we can run it from the
other term for now yeah let's just swap
these two cuz I have it set up in this
one I know for
semicolon so CD
build and then what is it it's python DM
HTTP dos server
8000 look at
this you see
it actually
works we are this one that's going in a
straight line and the rest of them are
moving
right so we actually have this
now I don't know how we just ate another
snake that was weird maybe it ran into
us if I run into one of these I should
die though right
uh I think I just ate it so that's
probably a bug right that you can eat
other
snakes that is kind of a funny mechanic
though if you think about
snakes well this whole thing works
I'm trying to see if I can get any of
them to
like oh there yeah there it goes so I
think if I run into it directly then I
do die but I think that they ran into me
is what happened something weird like
that anyways this works
now uh we can get way fancier with this
right we can do let's say we're going to
do 80 by 80 and do 16 snakes
and we're going to say
that cell size will be
five okay look at
this I don't know why we don't have our
16 snakes though we only have five
snakes that's a little weird
right I said 16
snakes oh maybe there's like an error
with this snake colors
okay but we we have like some idea now
for
sure uh what do we do next I think we
try to like make the full game work and
then we go to torch right yeah yeah
let's do
that I also think we're going to do some
local
builds there was one that wasn't moving
maybe they stacked
yeah something weird for
uhoh right there was this annoying FL
that we needed right this LD Library
flag where's the LD Library flag do we
have that from
before yeah this thing
game we can see that there are only four
snakes and that this works and that it
is
25 build
snake this is too
big still too
big 16
maybe and this is yeah this is perfect
so this
actions we definitely need actions as
well
num snakes times size of unsigned int
this looks good as well
right uh so something is weird that it's
not it's like capped on the number of
snakes also the snake colors thing is
weird well this right here is why it's
weird
default color green I don't like this
switch at all but we'll deal with this
for now
um yeah I think we're going to spend
some time today just cleaning up this
environment and then maybe tomorrow
we'll get to the torch stuff we'll
see but I think I have some engagements
for tomorrow which means I have to be
somewhat
awake this is really cool though I'm
actually like obviously this whole code
is just translated by Claude I mean I
did write the original in scyon which I
don't think would be too much worse I
don't think c will be too much worse
than
that uh I the only thing that's going to
be hard is like getting the original
like The Binding set up for how we're
going to do memory between Python and C
instead that'll be a little awkward um
but I think once we get that done like
this this could be very this could be
very reasonable
is there somewhere where it just didn't
allocate the right amount of
memory actually I have a whole bunch of
devs in chat um is there any way I can
check for out of bounds like
automatically it's like does like clang
or something have something to check for
out of bounds
but that would give me a really big hint
if something's writing out of bounds
it's probably because I allocated wrong
Val grind is like post talk for memory
right I was looking for
like do you know what the scon compile
flags are like how it just turns on
checks for like out of bounds and stuff
and obviously that'll slow down
performance but it lets you know if you
have anything wrong I'm looking for just
like compile flags that let me do sanity
checks I thought clang had some stuff I
don't know I was told that last week at
least so for reference here
like I learned C in
undergrad for some of my systems
classes and I didn't really do anything
in C outside of that again so I haven't
really used it for any substantial
projects
um I actually liked I remember that I
liked C more than C++ plus a lot even
back then and that definitely tracks
with
today but I don't like I don't know any
of the tooling that people use for
it unsigned into
actions learning scon from puffer scon
is good scon is really good there's no
performance reason for what I'm doing
right now like scon is just is going to
be just as fast as what I'm doing right
now the only reason I'm doing this is to
play around with a web
assembly that's literally
it if you want to like make cool high
perf Sims like puffer lib is 100% taking
PRS of like cool high perf Sims for
cases so this looks like it's allocating
the right amount of memory I don't see
where
this would possibly be going wrong
point is there not something I can put
in the
code oh yeah I forgot you had to do like
this that's obnoxious
well we should learn this we should
remember like how to do this stuff
anyways
right and then what do we do we do we
run it
with GDB
it actually getting a
debugger is nice the scon one was a pain
I remember so
this is actually kind of an
thus far there's actually nothing in
this C code that I say oh that's gross
overall come on give me
GDB 35 Megs geez
okay
awesome so
nice look at
that we got break
points oh actually this is really cool
so if you set break points inside of RB
like after RB is run uh usually this
crashes stuff but apparently in see it
doesn't that's nice
much look at that I really missed that
command it doesn't work in pdb you can't
like continue five
times that's
awesome wait this is kind of
int do this have random
data looks like it has random data
pdb when GDB walked in
yeah I mean I do miss is there a way to
do you can't just do like breakpoint or
something in the source file right
that's the set you can set breakpoints
in the code like not in pdb it's just
really
convenient like pdb has some really nice
Integrations like that
that's weird isn't
it isn't that weird
wait snake
colors yeah yeah so this is the this is
definitely an issue
oh
wait yeah I'm just an idiot that's
that's why oh I see the problem is I'm
an idiot yeah as always
this Star Puffer yes indeed folks if you
like any of this work I mean we're doing
silly stuff today but generally we are
pushing forward the frontiers of
reinforcement learning doing lots of
cool stuff here easiest way to support
this project for free is to just start
on GitHub it really helps me out a ton I
will put the link in the chat
thank you for the reminder linky
792 like this is really really awesome
growth got to keep it up though can't
level
out got to feed the
puff
what
yes all right
build
shell and it's going to tell me I don't
know how to write C and it's probably
going to be
yeah if it's if this is all you just P
PR
fine
there
we can see that we're the snake that's
really close to the red one right here
and we're the two long
snake and you can see that this actually
works quite
well so let's fix up some other stuff
with the code and the renderer so this
looks like the original and then we can
actually it's 309 we'll see how far we
get today I mean it's only 309 but the
thing is like I will actually probably
be asleep at 8:00 p.m.
so yeah you can only get so much done
when you need to sleep like 14 hours cuz
your body is thash to
hell I am feeling a little bit better
now than I was even like an hour or two
ago okay so I absolutely hate this
render logic
right yeah I don't think switch
statements are just like asking for
trouble I think this is
better not a huge fan of the extra
syntax like the extra p and stuff but I
just have to get used to that that's
just C for
the thing is I know that if you just
forget one of these brakes you're so
screwed
right yeah I think we're going to do um
we're going to do just if lfs for now on
this now let's actually Define the
correct
colors let me figure out where I have
those colors
here I don't I think I have them in
the
render yeah this one right here
you can emit them no you do not omit
them you can't you can't emit the
parentheses you can emit the the uh the
braces which I also think is generally a
bad
idea the reason it's a bad idea is
because um
it C does not take into account spacing
so like let's say that I put two lines
right then it will actually like if you
miss the the brace if I just put a line
below this it will run this code inside
of the El statement and then it'll run
this next piece of code uh not in the
elf statement so it's like a very it can
introduce very confusing bugs that's why
that's generally bad
practice that much I
remember remember a little bit of my
snake yeah okay so this
is this is bad um
we can just do like this can't
we and I don't know where these options
came from it should be
color
six 255
Z yeah know these are all wrong let's
just get rid of
and we can just
do
equals uh
colors cell like this right
what's the Syntax for
this yeah it's the other way around
right
okay so you can actually just do you
don't need to define the size that was a
scon [ __ ] thing
right and then this is a curly
brace see I get this is another annoying
thing with cython is it confuses you
with your C
syntax expected expression before
colors
equals that looks fine to
me expected
expression before
color uhuh
maybe you're not allowed to do it like
this is there just like some
weird can you not make it like
this there's probably some uh some like
SE struct
this wait
color
oh what is this
syntax I guess it's because it's Technic
it's a
struct so you have to do it
like wait it's like
this
all right this is just me not knowing
syntax that's
fine color is a struct containing
an no color should be an array
containing colors is an array that
contains elements that are that are
structs and each struct is a color I
think that's how you say it okay well
whatever it is this
worked so this looks way better now
right we can see where the red
right I I still think we're like eating
snakes I think that there's like there's
some weird logical inconsistencies here
it is technically possible that they're
like running into us before we run into
them or something but yeah this is this
is good overall I'd
this this is
empty food corpse and
Wall have you logged into RuneScape
today my friend I have not logged into
RuneScape in a very long time I think
it's been about a year um
that if that's considered a very long
time I uh that game is actually heroin
so my infernal Cape is going to have to
sit unused for a bit while I actually do
some
work game is actual
heroin it's such a good
game that's the problem it's too good so
instead I
only I only allow myself to play games
that are less fun so I don't get as
addicted to
them 338 Line's not
bad you never quit just on break yeah
seriously well hopefully we make that
break long enough to like I don't know
revolutionize a scientific
field look if I solve reinforcement
learning then I get to play as much
RuneScape as I like right but uh until
then got to revolutionize scientific
field you need to play RuneScape for
advancing RL Frontier h i mean neural
MMO like literally all of my work
basically came out of out of that like
like all the inspiration for all the
stuff I do it came out of like a really
really deep understanding of MMOs like
it wasn't just like hey wouldn't it be
cool if RuneScape but RL it was like
wait a second this is the exact perfect
type of environment to use for
reinforcement learning because the
underlying state representation is
ludicrously efficient and it contains a
variety of short and long-term tasks of
a type that are not available in the
rest of reinforcement learning like
there was a lot of stuff behind it like
that right so yeah
I mean like right down to like the tick
system the tile pathing and all that you
know all that stuff went into neural
MMO it all went into neural
MMO and I still use a lot of it
today I see we have a bunch of folks on
YouTube so
welcome uh all the stuff you're seeing
here is available it's all open source
it's in puffer
Leb which is right here I'll link it
it's all in the dev Branch at the moment
and uh if you want to help the project
for free just give it a star helps me
out a ton back to
Dev okay so now this environment mostly
Works um let's make sure it works on the
web just in case we screwed up anything
like really
major we shouldn't have screwed up
anything right but you never know
holy well
um I think that this is too
large and it's not
scrollable so we'll have to change that
okay that's way better
so this now does run on the
server this pretty
nice let me see if I can get a food so
you can just see where the snake is that
we're
controlling yeah there you go so you can
see that we're the two snake
solid webd yeah it's webd but it's
C which is the only way to do webd that
doesn't
suck serious seriously what does it say
about the state of modern tooling that I
would rather write see than
JavaScript so I guess now we can figure
out the uh the model integration
sadly this very nice C file is going to
have to become
C++ because the torch API is
C++ we're only going to need like 5 10
lines of C++
though um
we probably need to like first go get
the model
here let me make sure we actually have a
pre-trained model that we've already
there we
go this freaking fan this like case fan
of mine is like
vibrating the entire desktop which is
not
great I'll have to figure that out in a
bit default has no attribute encoder
okay so I guess we don't have a uh we
don't actually have a model
trained for the latest
version can we do that real quick
let's just do like a 200 mil step run
instead of 10 billion thank you very
much nice easy 200 mil
steps I think this still trains
right M
snake mode
train see if this
works hopefully I didn't break it
broken
pipe
on
snake yeah we need to set the
snake dot yeah okay so actually if I fix
this does this mean that we have uh a
eval
demo no still don't have really cool
looking render but we don't have uh eval
so we have to still train anyways that's
fine let's see if it
works train ourselves a new snake policy
oh yeah that's super fast right uh but
this is the wrong Network there's no way
it's 20K parameters
how about
now yeah there this is what we
this we'll see if this one okay this
one's still not up to date so we'll just
we'll train this now come
on back
multiprocessing Baseline
pipe
huh well that's
bizarre okay we'll just take this off I
have no idea why that doesn't work
that's
Dev I'm going to train this and while
this is training I'm going to figure out
why my CPU fan is just so
unhappy I think I'm probably going to
have to just remove that fan I think
it's just got a bad blade in
it yeah so we'll let this thing train
and then we'll stop doing super heavy
work like
this is like vibrating my desktop which
is not
optimal looks like it's learning you can
see the mean snake length is increasing
so they all like they have average
length 16 17 there you go uh so you can
see that this is very very fast to train
even on this local little desktop it
should be about three times faster than
this remote actually more than that
because um for some reason the V is not
working right now let me just make that
this freaking desktop is not spinning
itself apart cuz this fan is so
Jank yeah
okay um I'm just going to sit here
awkwardly and hold this until this thing
runs it's eight minutes for training
though I don't want to hold this for so
long is this going to break stuff if I
just unplug this
fan
like nope looks like you can just unplug
a
fan I probably shouldn't have done that
but we just unplug the
fan passive cooling plus CPU fan should
be
fine at least now it's no longer shaking
my entire
desk all right so this will take uh this
will take a little bit of time to train
in the meantime let's figure some stuff
out so I want to figure out the torch
script
here inspect the source code and compile
it
so I think what we're going to do is
we're going to
like
download we're going to have to figure
out how to download and script the
model and
then load torch
tracing okay so we're going to write
some like little tiny script like this
to trace and then save the model
right and we don't need to do this
that's
fine so we
save the tra B model and then we load to
C++ like right
here deserialize aor loading the model
okay
G last thing we need to do is
build lib
torch okay so this is the stuff will was
complaining about that's fine
so you
have
inputs okay so we're going to make we're
going to see if we can figure this out
then like the the thing that's going to
be hard here there are a couple things
that are going to be hard so one is
figuring out how to build all this stuff
and then the other thing that's going to
be annoying is we have to figure out how
to load uh C data into torch right
cool how's this model doing training
very well it looks like be done in
another five minutes actually like this
is already a good model like this
literally we could have just done a f
minute train in like completely
suboptimal conditions and been fine um
okay
so let's
some Claud
snake. compute observations we're going
to make Claude try to do it because
we'll
also decent use cases just totally
unfamiliar working like libraries and
tools
um so what we do
is oh is the uh
can you give it a link as a reference
does this
work I think you're allowed to you can
give it links right
fine
yeah let's see what it does
tensor so this does a copy this is
garbage code but we'll see if it does
anything I do like that it put these
separately and then
this is all
c yeah the only it only uses
the uh C++ for the torch
API and
C
set
paste cool so now we have
this we still need Snak model. PT so
we'll have to go get
that and then yeah we'll see how this
API works and then we'll optimize it
after this but basically the idea here
is that if this works so this is 97
lines of code the other one is a little
bloated at like 300 and something so say
after we finish like cleaning all this
stuff up we end up with a 400 line demo
file that is running a a policy that
will control like 4,000 snakes in real
time with your GPU in the browser and
then you can like play you can basically
play snake with all the
AIS and it'll work like
done so for folks that are new to this
um this C stuff I'm doing today is kind
of a
one-off the main thing I work on here is
puffer
Le which um if we want to see how useful
puffer is so we've just trained this
snake policy ludicrously fast uh it
synced to WB right here I
believe and we can see we get all the
graphs we get the reward overtime we can
see that it's learned we get the mean
snake length we get all these nice stats
and we're also going to get the model
output to here so we're going to just be
able to curl the model file in a moment
it's doing a little bit of extra
evaluation right now this is another
feature so it gives us a very stable
evaluation at the very end adds like an
additional I don't know maybe one minute
or
so we'll go from
there good to see Stone got a little bit
of promo out of
before almost done right yeah there we
go is
done and now we'll just grab our model
file
is
curl l- o
snake
d
t we'll grab this
file and then uh we needed to
jit we needed to J it right
uh
get
model
so don't need torch
Vision load let's make model.
VT example you need to give it an
example
input uh
16 was it
11 we'll have to figure out what the
model is going to
take and
then race model with example and then
torch. jit do
saave yeah so this is what we
want um
do we want to give this yeah torch
do you and 8 I
believe check uniform bounds not
implemented for
bite I don't think we have to give it a
unate I think we can just give it the
default which will be like float 32 or
whatever input and Cuda type should be
the
same okay map location we're going to
map it to CPU
um probably
because hold on
yeah because right here we one hot the
observations the way to do this
08 I don't know why the hell it just
totally [ __ ] up the shape
here
11 device equals
CPU TR this
again still
no okay
maybe interesting that this still is
weird 64
okay this
works uh that's kind of weird but I
think it
works we will see how this works uh in a
bit but for
now maybe this is good
enough and we have torch
model snake model. PT snake model trace.
PT
[Music]
snake and we're going to just compile
this locally
like why I would love to know why this
just fails without oh wait no it doesn't
fail I'm just dumb it's because I have
Claud
snake torch
and I can't gccc a.
C++ I got to get the make file horeshit
right so maybe I should just like leave
this be like
this um and we're going to have to do
like a new make file
snake game and this is going to
be Claude
snake tch.
and we're going to give this again to
Claude because I do not know what the
hell I'm doing
here um
P
torch docks give me this
cake text or
build and I have this
G for the original C file
RB okay let's see if this gives us
anything
okay we're just going to blindly apply
this without even considering anything
whatsoever
directory
um build
cake could not
[Music]
find add the
installation or set
it's supposed to find this though and
it's not finding it
right I'm just going to give this to
freaking Claude
package
append what is path to lib
that P torch
torch where the hell is that
answer ah okay I think I do need to just
did install
this let me
see torch
one for
Linux
C++
12.1 with Cuda why
not which one of these do I want I want
probably this C plus cxx 11 this thing
uhuh
oh
forch do zip
okay uh this should go substantially
faster than it is currently
that but yeah I didn't realize I need to
have
specifically C++ lib torch
yeah there it goes their speed is fixed
now I'll be here in like five
minutes so yeah the plan is going to be
that if we can get oh because it was
downloading this in the background F
fine so this will be done in like 3
minutes then we're good
um So the plan is going to be that we
get this we figure out how the heck to
do all this compilation
Shenanigans we get this running locally
in a web Dem demo that'll take a little
time uh probably we're not going to be
able to do everything everything with
this today but like either tomorrow or I
have some co-working stuff so maybe
Friday we'll do we'll see if we can get
like this nicely polished up with just
like a simple setup put it into the dev
Branch
proper and then yeah maybe from there
we'll see how this goes it'll definitely
go on the
website and then I'll sort of like go
look around at this and I'll see whether
this is more generally like a good way
of doing stuff or not but for an initial
little demo this is probably pretty
good and even just having like one
EnV uh online for puffer is going to be
pretty
cool I mean I'd like to say like hey
could you imagine if I did like the
whole MOBA online but I don't know we'll
see how annoying it is to maintain like
the C code I think I'm going to have to
refactor it a fair bit as well because
like it's done all 1D indexing for
everything first of all that's just not
sustainable and it's done a few other
things that are like kind of Jank so I
think it's going to want to use 2D
arrays and a few other things but it's
pretty
close we see how nice we can get
project that wasn't that bad we get Li
torch
us and we will have reinforcement
learning but C
right
yeah
I cannot find
Cuda please set the proper Cuda prefixes
or install
Cuda do I not have like a standalone
Cuda
install because I think I just get Cuda
through pie torch
right no it should be because I
have no I have the Nvidia Cuda base
container we're going to just keep going
on claw
here please just do things actually
we'll try to not use the capacity we'll
do
here Duda
paths I'm in in
container oh [ __ ] I don't have the dev
because I don't have the updated
container okay that's
obnoxious yeah I got to install the CPU
version of pytorch for now that sucks I
forgot that I have I have the uh the new
containers but I haven't updated the
local to them
right yeah cuz they don't have nvcc that
sucks well I think their
CPU build should hopefully be smaller so
that should be quicker
Linux lib
torch one
CPU
copy l-
o we'll download
this and this should be yeah way smaller
obviously because it doesn't have Cuda
this is Tiny this is actually very very
nice for us
and way less
stuff way faster is also very
nice um
build cake dot
dot oo build files have been
I think I just
make on this is chat jeppy
does move this a little bit can't see my
command line there we go so we get an
error rayb okay this is I know how to
fix this
one right
wait I'm trying to think if I have the
path wrong
okay so we're still getting the
link errors so let's just assume that
the original path was
probably good so
RB
five Doo so this is this is
here uh it should be able to find this
Target link
libraries lib
r.o should not
specify okay does it have a new cake for
me what do we think do we think that
this is right or do we think that this
is [ __ ]
okay hold
[Music]
and lib
C10 doso what
buffer tank buffer
lib uh poer
lib ocean
know needs lib Ray lib as well doesn't
it
okay so when you set these paths this
actually
works then we get error loading the
model model loaded
successfully and then it's seg fals
doing okay so we're actually not even
getting to
um to reset the en and stuff right
failing okay so it is actually resetting
the
environment and oddly enough this when w
this window should close is the thing
that's breaking
it it's very
weird um let me
see
rib I could do rib Source lib RB let me
see about
snake
lib Flash
Source says
Source
yeah and then what's the other one
there's an Nvidia path isn't
stuff can't link lib r.o
okay so um I guess we're going to have
to
do thing is the other one really should
have
here man it like all this was fine while
we were in Sealand and then as soon as
we get this freaking C++ build
everything goes to [ __ ] it just goes to
show you like
okay we
get error while loading libraries
one modify this to include this
full
okay could not
set Target properties can build
stuff torch
rib RB 5. l
Linux MD
fine configuring incomplete errors
occurred cannot find Target to add
properties to snake game okay
name I don't know the thing is I don't
know what this is
before the target is defined I did
Define the
Target and
then wait set
property all the way down
there I thought you would just have to
set the project name
okay Target link libraries and then
here we do this right
wait they changed a lot of stuff here
didn't
they wait add
executable are do we just take this
whole
file damn it language models this is why
I say these tools are SLO
like the only reason I'm using this at
the moment is because like I'm
completely incapable at what I'm doing
like if I had the slightest idea what I
were doing I would not be using any of
this I'm just trying to like get some
basic stuff to work and there you go out
of free messages
great well I'll probably just swap the
GPT subscription for this anyways let's
see if this works
okay so now we get back to where we were
before where we are resetting the
environment and then seg
falting okay without all the export
Shenanigans I guess
environment oh okay it does it seg folds
inside of
reset so what happens if I you
know
[Music]
Star St
slash I'm sure what's going to happen is
then stuff is going to not work but
let's
see I just want to see if I can get it
to reset the
Define what does it actually want me to
Define no
okay so still resetting the environment
is seg
falting
um that's got to
be I mean that just straight up doesn't
make sense right like the environment
itself should not be S
fting that was not seg folting before
and I didn't change anything
so something to do with the way that
this is compiling or maybe not
so this is what it's trying to compile
right and it needs
RB doesn't it need lib as well yeah here
it
is
right but I don't is this actually what
is causing
vaults no failures right nothing weird
with
RB nit
renderer I'm assuming it's something
with the render like if I just do this
right back this suddenly now takes so
damn long to compile is annoying as hell
too I don't understand the whole build
chain and frankly I have no desire to
understand the C++ build chain
like really this still seg fult in
resetting the environment not in the
renderer
okay
so compiled it
before and it
worked I compile it now with the C++
build and it doesn't
work
great is there any way to debug this
type of a thing
it's so obnoxious that the torch API is
a C++
API otherwise we wouldn't have to do any
of this [ __ ]
background no it doesn't
right no it's
yeah trying and think what we can figure
out here
[ __ ] how the hell did US switching this
compilation caused the environment
itself to seg Vault
like L D DL
RT P thread m
l Li
weird should give us
status we have status
information this looks good to
me the torch library is also look fine
like
jeez can you do that can GDB find seg
fults for me like that wait hold on
right just like this random spot in the
environment that doesn't make sense to
me
Po
okay um
what how was the head pointer this
screwed up
where was
I
oh this is freaking bizarre did
something get screwed up in the
reset like
what something's very very weird
so these are supposed to be zeroed on a
it aren't
they so I guess like it's just instead
like I was getting lucky before and now
I'm malaking bites that are not
like
wait single block of memory
okay so we have to do the size of it's
different okay
like this
right does this still guaranteed to give
you contiguous
yes oh wait Malik doesn't give you
contiguous that's
interesting that's weird
[ __ ] and the speed doesn't matter here
because this isn't in it
anyways probably should have just been
doing this from the start uh in the
original code I do think I depend on
this being zeroed so it makes sense that
this was failing here
and probably like just loading all the
torch crap like I don't know polluted
memory or something who
knows okay so we actually this is good
we get we get past the end of error and
we get to where we expected stuff to go
wrong which is
in uh the torch stuff
so this is actually exactly exactly what
we want
Trace back
shape 16 x 11 by
are because this is failing where this
is failing in the Ford call isn't
it well this straight up makes no sense
this like I don't know why I let LMS
just write this slop code but
um yeah this makes literally no sense
oh you have to give it a state as well
don't
let's go get the uh the Claud API
upgraded so we can just lean on that for
now uh because I don't I really don't
know what the hell in uh I mean I've
never I've never used the torch C++ API
right I don't know what the heck is
going on here let me go get this uh this
upgraded
it cool let's give it
now let's give it all of
let me go get the model API from
puffer my own model
API TM
wrapper hidden critic
State I think I can just find it in
clean puff RL
do we not have a forward function I
thought we did have a forward
function oh yeah right it's right
here get action and value
anything it's pretty crazy that oops
it's pretty crazy that it generates all
this without being able to run any of
the
code of course it gets it wrong most of
time okay so it creates a
tensor with the correct shape
okay yeah I forget if it's 255 let's we
can check that real
quick
torch it's whatever they oh it's uh 128
it looks
like 128 okay
so let's just take this code it's
probably better than what we
have and what did they say 256 they
hardcoded
somewhere like this
does make sure a trace Model includes
lstm State
handling oh okay you might need to trace
the model
with okay I didn't realize
that
uh how do we go and do we need to like
trace the model
differently well first of all I mean
this is not
even this is like straight up the wrong
number of inputs so that actually could
be from the trace couldn't it that could
totally be from the
Is Well
we'll push on it a little bit for
now let's not even waste
the API call let's I think we can just
figure this
out
Zer 16
no it
doesn't data one. shape of
one equal to the batch
okay right there's like an extra
Dimension that I forgot about isn't
there I think I can go get this from the
I can get this from Puffer
and there should be State allocated
somewhere
here probably in experience
here numb layers agents hidden
size so there's a one that I was
okay so that doesn't help we get the
exact same error
oops this seriously not going to paste
in a reasonable
way yeah there we
go and
then oh cannot access your reference
links right
the
[ __ ]
what no we're not doing
arguments recurrent
policy let's see maybe we can figure
this out ourselves from the API
so we see it's
in puffer lib Frameworks I
uh no it doesn't take two arguments it
takes more than two
arguments one two three
four yeah so this is the return type is
good here but why does it think that it
doesn't
take it thinks that this none argument
is invalid or something what
the two arguments for operator
forward in clean our recurrent
policy
self wait is
know yes okay I didn't copy the the new
scripted model in so the scripted model
was the the jitted model was correct I
just didn't copy it in okay so we got
farther
here so what happens incorrect number of
RNN parameters
we can deal with this
right yeah we can totally deal with this
now
okay this is totally wrong right here
this is
128 let's make we should make this
so oh man why are these error messages
such [ __ ]
holy
hell internal assert failed
great expected tupple but got
tensor hold on tenser
H where's the Ford call
right man where is this happening in
this Source though I don't even
okay so this this needs to be updated
for the I think that we just need to
update this for
the the five tensor API or
whatever which I think Claude already
actually did for us
right right here they
did
back okay but this is not quite right
it's kind
oops okay
so so you get model forward inputs.
oh now it's Auto completing I guess okay
we're
good
output action log entropy
value lstm
topple and then we'll do
H and see like this maybe
answer holy hell whoa guys it's
working
uh what the [ __ ] do we actually have it
hold
tenser I it was working on one of them I
saw right
update
actions wait something is really weird
here let me
okay still too big let's make this half
this size or like 16's probably good
right let's just do this and then we can
see and we can really debug
this it's definitely controlling some of
these snakes correctly though
okay okay well there's no food nearby
right so these things need
food like
so
um
100% C
C++ snake game anybody
core and um barely taxing the desktop as
well
that's pretty
cool you know it's going to be even
cooler we have this running in a
browser cross platform after all isn't
crazy let me get add these files before
I lose stuff
is there anything else in here I really
need
model that's
fine
okay
cmake
okay cmake option build
it's really funny because as effective
as this is at the moment I absolutely
hate this
workflow um this is like trash trash
garbage
workflow isn't that
funny what was that
book novel yeah city of
November there was this funny thing in
this like really old like 2003 book
about like this society that was
maintaining this like crazy old super
complicated generator that nobody know
how it worked and like it was just
getting worse and worse over time
because they were just like you know
following the old without really
understanding anything that's kind of
what happens with freaking letting
language models do everything so this is
slowly getting worse and worse and I'm
going to have to rain it in but uh you
know it is good enough to get a demo
thrown together as like a one day thing
but God if I just did this every day
this would just produce so much bad code
so
quickly local
build web build
why did this make game
do
uh this is the old build this is not the
version that we
oh I bet it just did the old the old
files
right
yeah it's here
right okay so it just get misunderstood
okay that's
long chats cause you to reach loose so I
guess it's just based on like input
tokens or
is this what it was
before hold
on okay this current cake
[Music]
settings so it's set
cake prefix
up so what we're going to do is we're
going to just
do we're going to try this again new
chat well this didn't paste right at all
let's go get it off of
GitHub good thing I saved it
right for
local andand this see make to have two
compile
options
local it's now and web which will
snake game.
HTML clad snake
torch
RB yeah this is good
let's see if this does
anything why did it do a pop out like
this
weird
error torch script. H not found
torch I see is it
not it's not doing okay I'm just going
to have to edit this normally because
it's just not getting stuff um
here what do I need to add for M script
and let me see if I can just figure this
out so
there's a lot of
similar the Raab links are all
different yeah a lot of the RB stuff is
different
actually so let me see how different
this thing
is if I just copy this and put it at the
bottom like
dude I actually don't understand how the
[ __ ] people program like
this like just fighting in llm all day
without understanding anything is just
feels God awful
hell okay so we're here we got to do
where's this make flag for
us find torch is not okay so let's just
freaking
torch is not readily
available
yeah okay well this is not what it needs
to do so stop doing that
new you can replace shared with static
and get URLs like
this they exist we generate them
if we just go all the way to the bottom
does it still
hell somebody's got to have done this
right
web is this a
thing nope I don't want freaking
JavaScript piss
off go away no JavaScript thank you
though
actually nope still no JavaScript I
technically if that's the only way of
doing it I could have it's not that bad
because let me
think no because then I'd need to expose
C observations to JavaScript somehow
which would be just as bad as C++
garbage these are also
old
this you can basically just tell
whenever you have a video that looks
like this this is like some shill
this
okay so you can export these models
right
still can execute on GP
[Music]
okay so this looks like it maybe works
but then how do
I thought you could Define hold on
there's got come on there's no like
pytorch web assembly
um you don't need a freaking JavaScript
front end I just need this to compile to
web
assembly and it says that they used to
do it and now that they don't anymore
let me think practically what can I do
here
like
onyx wasum
Onyx
TCH yeah it's a totally different HX
that's
funny uh Wasim
C++ build for web
FAQ is this a thing I think you can do
this wait let me see
cake there's like a thing here but I
don't understand what the hell it's like
so there's tiny little bit of
documentation Onyx runtime web
assembly.
second inferencing
like is there a Capi wait hold on
ooh this is what we want isn't it this
is the same
Onyx
wait tensor yeah yeah this is
better this will be actually
substantially substantially better
okay so here's what we're going to do
we're going to just like take all this
we're going to say that we fine
here let's go grab the original code so
we have all this
and then
copy torch one
modify okay it doesn't actually know
know what is happening
here I think the context is useful
though so here's what we're going to do
we're going to give it the
okay so it
does you know I'm actually I'm way
happier with a bunch of Loops copying
data around than I am with whatever the
hell the C++ faction Anin was before
lines it could be worse
all right this looks good
right and we'll need to get the Onyx run
time
what why is this
net how the [ __ ] do I get this thing
net
uh wait this is
C am I nuts here like what
this oh this
right yeah okay I just couldn't find the
link because they had their net [ __ ]
at the top
here
and all we have to do
[Music]
is copy this thing right
linked for local
Yep this is the same as before which is
what it should
be slowly this the insanity is
diminishing I will actually be even
though the like the API is kind of
garbage looking I will be very very
happy if we can somehow figure out how
to do this without having to use
C++ we can just do all this and
see okay so where do we fail here
shell file not
the other option would be let's try to
build
this there is a doso but there's no for
web
uh-oh so that's not going to
Android wait how do you get can you not
get this compiled for web
bro I don't want this I want the
freaking binaries
this was in the Q&A wasn't it maybe I
understand what this is now
C
Onyx you just linked me the front page
man I'm looking for
um I'm looking for binaries I can just
use I'm looking for like you know lib
was. or whatever I can just use from
C we basically we have everything
working except we can't get P torch
models to run on the web go to the
release
page I think I was just
so what do you mean it doesn't serialize
well to web I can compile I can export
as can
I
um so these don't come compiled for web
as far as I can tell like I have right
here I got the 6 I got the uh this build
here and I don't have I don't have a
a torch you can export P torch models to
Onyx
should work fine for this we have
relatively simple models
right unless they don't support lstms or
something stupid
lstm why not
use the Onyx
runtime because okay I guess what we're
doing today is a little bit
silly so I
have Claud snake. H so I have this this
is a pure C
implementation of the snake
environment and it runs well um I don't
think I have it compiled at the moment
maybe I do let me
see okay look so here this is pure C and
C++ running uh a pre-trained pytorch
model locally with this snake M that is
in pure C and I can run everything up
here I can run this on the web as well
except that pytorch is not building for
web they don't seem like they ex they
don't seem like they have a web build
anymore they used to and it seems like
they don't anymore so the next thing I
was thinking is okay instead of using
the pytorch C++ API maybe we can export
to Onyx and use the Onyx C API which
would be even better I'd like to not
even have any C++ if I can just do it
all in
C
um but I can't
find I can't find their web build uh if
they have
one like I can't find just something I
can use like this from C they have like
node packages and [ __ ] but I don't want
I definitely don't want any
JavaScript would be really cool because
I'd be able to have this as like a
standalone and I'd be able to have this
on web right
called oh that might be it let me
see uh I think I was on there let me see
no wait you might have it
hold
on web assembly
artifacts ninja the
[ __ ] DK
okay so I have to do all this [ __ ] to
get this to
run
Jesus okay 6 pm I'll do a little bit
more of this today
God anytime you get web anything just
everything goes to [ __ ]
like I don't
know literally anytime anything is on
the web it's like just garbage I
swear yeah this is what we need
here okay let's figure out if I can at
least export the model to Onyx first
okay so it's basically the
same exact thing as before just instead
of scripting it's on
P it doesn't [ __ ] work as the
problem like it just [ __ ] doesn't
work I tried a while ago and I couldn't
get anything to work like you realize
like the amount of stuff that has to run
here right like okay then the
environment is going to be in scon right
the models are in torch somehow torch
has to run in the browser which isn't
going to work
like there's just no way of doing it
dude what the [ __ ] is wrong with my
suggest today
dot what the
[ __ ] stupid language
models no onx
script you have to do this I think
okay so this does export the model cool
so it looks like we this is actually
worth doing if we can export our models
let's start from here
you know this was supposed to be
easy I mean I guess
technically this could be the case that
like once I just have all the build
stuff in place the
actual the actual code behind everything
ends up being easy right because if you
think about it everything is just in
C that has a very nice appeal to
it that should mean no
cake that should
mean basically just like GCC you know or
M script in I guess you still need M
script
in artifacts for every architecture we
have SIMPLE architectures this isn't
meant to be C like Global whatever for
puffer this is just meant to be like
let's ship some really simple demos
where you have like a 400 line file
that's like here's the entire
environment implementation and the
renderer and the model you know forward
pass inference and it just runs locally
on web on like a CPU and it runs 4,000
agents in real time or
that it's just so obnoxious how it's
like honestly the only thing that hasn't
been crazy today is the C everything
else all the tooling around everything
has been
[ __ ] computer
architecture is it not just web assembly
am I being dumb
cursed it's like the entire web stack
just needs to be like a nuked and a
redone I don't know how it is that like
we have such good simple things that
make sense on back end and then just
like the entire web is just on fire
you would think we would have solved
that by now in a way that doesn't
require going
insane and that's not that's totally not
the only issue like the web is like this
framework that framework it's constantly
like I don't know you can just tell the
the way stuff is done is really
[ __ ] like why the hell do I need Python
and node in order to compile C to web
assembly
okay so here we have
this do I have
node are you kidding me I don't have
[ __ ]
I thought I had
node on the docker oh I guess not on the
latest ones Maybe
okay we got
node we have
python got ninja right we did this
already yeah we did that
this backend has multiple
Frameworks you just listed a [ __ ] ton of
web stuff
you just listed back in stuff like for
web appli like web
applications what D Jango no Django is
for web isn't
it who the [ __ ] uses this
otherwise yeah
okay so here's this but we don't do this
right it
has an
FAQ so I think what we do is we copy
this and then we
see
okay and then it
says build wasm
use build wasum static
lib running is Route is not
allowed I'm in a Docker container are
you [ __ ] me
spelled
[ __ ] got to update cake as well freaking
drive me abs absolutely batshit
the amount of garbage I've had to
install is
command I know somebody sent it to me
hold
on what in the hell
make
yeah
okay I see how we did
like you'd have to have like I don't
know
JavaScript somehow run the
network there's not even like a torch JS
so you're still going to be an onyx land
doesn't even really save you
much e
[ __ ] man it's crazy that the web
ecosystems this terrible like what in
the hell
is basically anytime I have to touch
JavaScript or C++ I am not
happy I will gladly do c no C++
please could not find open SSL are you
kidding me oh Li SSL Dev right [ __ ]
sake rewrite your ment tensor flow JS
you [ __ ] kill me now
please
Jesus it's just like it's so sad
because like running this on the web
would be so nice and it's just like this
rib is
awesome it just works on the web the C
simulator works just works on the web
web it's
fine the only thing that doesn't
work well I guess if I'm thinking about
it right the only thing that doesn't
work is the models right
now so I mean I can make them playable
if I just made some dumb little scripted
AI but you want to be able to play it
with the the actual models right that's
the thing
shouldn't even be that hard has anybody
made like a p torch to numpy network
thing or not numpy because numpy is uh
well numpy has a c API don't they has
anybody done like a you know like run
models in C numpy instead
work I could also just implement this
specific neural net architecture in
C and just load the
weights
right TF light
see that actually would be we'll see
I'll oops I'll keep going on this for a
little bit but that actually might be a
lot that might be less cancer than what
I'm doing now
I mean especially because all my neural
network architectures are pretty similar
right like and I don't need to implement
autograd
that's actually kind of appealing now
that I'm thinking about
it it would still be plenty fast for
like even reasonably sized
environments and then what would I need
left I just
need I mean everything else I have works
it would just have to be m scripton
web inference framework support more
backends write it yourself and
see GG ml Also may be
reasonable web inference what do you
mean web inference framework support
more back end what do you mean like C
like run it and Cuda or whatever
web GPU CPU
yeah no if I didn't it and see it would
just be
CPU but that also means I don't have GPU
problems right
wum is this a reasonably sized
project oh yeah
so what they'll just give
me can I like load models into
this I have to
look let's see if the Onyx thing
works so I got cake right and now where
the hell was I why was I doing all this
again
oh right because of this
[ __ ] excuse
me
oh uh I'm in the wrong
Onyx supports um GPU as well which would
be nice
so much
stuff the thing is the only reason I'm
still doing this I'm like thinking like
okay well this might not be that bad is
like this might just have an annoying
build chain but like if the actual code
itself is relatively simple and stable
like I can just make sure I have a good
version of cake good version of Onyx
good version of like lib torch I can
have everything just set up on a Docker
and then you know it'll just be like
okay puffer tank you know easyc build
environment done right and then the
actual code you're writing from there is
just not bad at
all I should order some food
CU I'm going to start getting tired
soon let me just do that on the side
figure out what to
awake man I was so freaking tired
before um I'm trying to think what even
want to get
I didn't have a protein shake I should
get a lot of something with like lots of
meat [ __ ] now I actually don't know
it's
weird place I thought was there is not
showing up how's this doing still
working why is finding reasonable food
so difficult around
now because I do need to get to sleep
early I've been sleeping like 12 hours
it's
ridiculous the recovery is
rough curious how big the binary you'll
be shipping to the user will be once
this is
done I don't know
then I'm going to have to do something
else
right you should be able to run Onyx on
the web though
C++ I totally get the IDE the appeal of
just doing it all and C right
like because I could do that I could
just make my own
little inference thing for a specific
net I actually saw David hod does that
in his slime volley environment like the
opponent is actually a neuronet that he
pre-trained or whatever but like he just
made the neuronet like he just like
copied the weights into numpy eras and
just manually does like five lines of
board like inference to have the
neuronet control the
opponent it pretty funny
not the most efficient thing in the
world of
generally fairly tile tiny mostly dense
layers in
lstm they're also conv vented as well
which is
annoying the thing that's a little bit
annoying about this is like itd probably
end up with like a thousand
line or like you know maybe at least 500
line like net like you know model Doh or
whatever file
CSV I mean you would think onx should
work though isn't this what it was made
for isn't it made to be like Closs
crossplatform
models
everywhere format
thing and this what is
for on Facebook you like use this to
deploy their like deploy their
production models and [ __ ]
file that's
good there's some architecture
stuff quantization as
what the
hell they're like kernels where are the
actual
this
interesting I like the way they're doing
stuff I mean this is checking the the
all the boxes so I might just try this
if this doesn't work
going to be uh having dinner though
pretty shortly here I see we still have
a few folks on YouTube so um this is a
little bit unconventional what we're
doing today I might do more of this
depending um I mean we're going to see
at least I'll like spend like the extra
day or whatever it's going to take to
get the full end to end on this and
we're going to see what comes out of it
but um in general we're doing lots of
stuff for high performance really simple
reinforcement
learning uh it's pretty much all in
Python but there's Ultra fast simulators
in syon as
well and it's all open source right here
so if you want to support the project or
check it out give it a star helps me out
a
compiling gez
freaking onx
man let me see what this looks like in
the
meantime maybe this is
they have [ __ ] docks admittedly do they
have any docks box
here okay so there's a huging face
introduction
is this thing optimized to like gigantic
models or is this reasonable for small
stuff as
well I've got meetings and stuff
tomorrow so probably we won't get to
play with this until
um uh we won't get to play with this for
a bit uh
got like a few minutes until food is
here we made good progress though like
even the model running locally in
C++ is
nice I'm just thinking like how easy
would it be to just freaking find see
implementation of everything
there it's probably not that much
lstm from scratch and
see it's not that
hard but the thing is it's just deeper
than I wanted to go for this like one
little
thing
right that's the main annoyance it's
just more than I wanted to do for this
one thing
it's all
llms I don't know why the hell you would
want llms in
wam well this is not going to be done
building
let me see if this looks
reasonable relatively
recent oh this is literally yesterday
okay
you got to be kidding me this is their
[ __ ] code for a mat
this is what they do to do a m mle are
you [ __ ]
me no piss
no that's like that's
horeshit we're not [ __ ] doing
that was this the one that you linked
me dude this
what what is the hell is this even
like
what all they did is show you how to
write 200 lines to do a single matrix
insane stick with Onyx or just write it
and C anything would be less painful I
mean we can do what was uh where's
Andre's thing right
yeah that's insane that's like
way that's too low level to even be
useful
right the Carpathia stuff is good
here I'm pretty sure that you could in
like 400 Lines Just Define the whole
architecture for uh the forward pass of
you know one of our
networks though it probably would take a
fair bit of optimization which would be
annoying the annoying
we'll definitely try with Onyx first
though because I don't really want to go
straight to
that my food
so I mean the results of today though
right is
like hold
on the result of
today is like we have this thing running
locally the whole m is in C the P torch
that is loaded with their C+ plus
API um the render is in C with rayb the
actually will work on web it's just the
pytorch uh API that
doesn't
so all we have to do is figure out a way
that's not incredibly painful to run
models in the
web
and
yeah we'll see how we can do that
hopefully we can find a way and
then the thing I want to have is I want
to have like a 400 line file that's like
here's the entire n implementation and
the renderer and the model load and the
model forward Loop and like it just runs
in your browser that is the
goal I think it's doable as long as we
can find one of these like on like these
uh web Frameworks that doesn't suck
I mean technically we could always do
like JavaScript side models but I really
don't want to do
that I'm trying to think if I don't want
to do that more than I don't want to
write the forward pass and
see I think I don't want to do the
JavaScript and it's not even close the
funny part with that how much I hate
JavaScript
like if there were like a built-in pie
torch thing like a pie TCH JS or
whatever then maybe but there isn't one
so like it's not going to be good
yeah has anybody written like a really
minimal didn't wait didn't carpy have
one of these
oh wait no this is George hz's hz's
stuff wait does this thing do
wome wait does tiny gr do
wome now this is all freaking python
right
oh wait tiny grad has
wasum okay
stuff okay I might look into this we'll
look into a few back ends before we do
something stupid like you know try to
implement the whole thing and see
ourself I'd rather do like M's and c not
have to be doing my own freaking neural
Nets and C
but I think that's it guys we're going
to call it for today um I'm going to go
get some food I might be on a little bit
in the morning tomorrow we'll see how
much sleep I need so I might get a
little bit done um but probably Friday
for the most part we will continue with
this uh we're going to try Onyx and then
we'll see like tiny grad and a few other
things and then if not then maybe I'll
just punt on it for now and I'll like I
don't know I'll find some silly thing to
do to make like at least something work
I mean technically I could always just
like decide you know screw it I'm going
to train a uh I'm just going to train
like a a two- layer MLP on this problem
instead so it won't be as good of a
model but maybe it'll still learn
something and then if I just do that
then like I can Implement that and C so
easily right it'll be like 100 lines of
code and we'll just have our own
Standalone I could always do that um it
would be really nice to have the full
models though so I don't know we'll see
but like this is not going to be like a
onee project of trying to get networks
to run on the web that's going to be
ridiculous so I'll give it like a
reasonable amount of time and then if
not I'll do something simpler um but
yeah this will be the goal of this is
just have an EnV from Puffer that is
high perf that can also be demoed on the
web and we'll see where that goes I'll
like I'll be able to post it people will
be able to play with it and if that does
well then you know we'll uh we'll go
from there anyways um thanks folks I
will be back hopefully fully recovered
tomorrow or close to it but
uh yeah give the puffer a star helps me
out a whole ton other than that see you
around